deux troupes russes à la frontière
moscou préoccupé par la situation de
l'armée ukrainienne qui aurait commencé
à bombarder et la banlieue de dawn y est
selon le maire de la ville d'après kiev
depuis samedi deux militaires
d'ukrainiens auraient été tués dans des
combats avec les séparatistes du dombass
en haïti sept religieux catholiques ont
été enlevés par un gang armé hier près
de la capitale port-au-prince parmi eux
deux français une religieuse et un
prêtre
une enquête a été ouverte à paris des
ravisseurs réclament un million de
dollars en mars le pouvoir exécutif
haïtien avait décrété l'état d'urgence
pour un mois dans certains quartiers en
raison de l'emprise grandissante des
gangs
[Musique]
objectif du gouvernement faire face à la
crise du coc vie d'un déconfinement me
met alors pour tenir cette ligne la
cadence vaccinale est supposé accéléré
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite
thomas bonnet en direct du stade de
france transformée en vaccinodromes
bonsoir thomas la campagne de
vaccination où en sommes-nous exactement
eh bien on est passé du nombre record de
510 milles injection vendredi à 100
milles ce dimanche alors c'est quand
même plus que le dimanche précédent mais
à titre d'illustration le stade de
france le vaccinodromes du stade de
france étaient fermés hier faute de
doses foot de personnel on n'est pas
encore donc dans le fameux 7 jours sur 7
souhaitée par le président de la
république alors le vaccinodromes du
stade de france a rouvert ses portes ce
lundi on a vu en fin d'après-midi tout à
l'heure files d'attentes assez
importante de personnes souhaitant donc
se faire vacciner on le rappelle le
principe même de vaccinodromes avait
d'abord été écarté par olivier ferrand
qui a finalement changé de braquet mais
pour s'assurer de l'efficacité de ces
méga centres de vaccination il va
falloir compter sur un approvisionnement
important en matière de doses de vaccins
et thomas pour accélérer le rythme le
gouvernement va bientôt pouvoir
s'appuyer sur un nouveau sérum celui de
johnson and johnson
il sera disponible à partir de mercredi
en france 200 mille doses devraient
arriver dans la semaine selon les
autorités sanitaires avantage important
pour le calendrier fixé par le
gouvernement puisque ce vaccin ne
nécessite qu'une seule injection cela va
permettre de vacciner davantage surtout
que depuis aujourd'hui les personnes de
plus de 55 ans sont éligibles à la
vaccination en france mais face aux
craintes de pénurie oliveira a également
annoncé l'espacement du temps entre les
deux injections de vaccin arn message il
va passer cet espacement de 28 à 42
jours à partir de mercredi présentée
comme une évolution des connaissances
scientifiques cet aménagement va surtout
permettre de vacciner davantage et
autres nouveautés de ce lundi thomas la
mise sur le marché des autotests c'était
assez longtemps qu'on les attendait
après donc de longs mois d'hésitations
oui la france faisait un peu exception
dans ce domaine puisque les autotests
sont très largement répandu dans un
certain nombre de pays européens mais
depuis ce lundi donc le dispositif est
enfin disponible pour les personnes de
plus de 15 ans initialement il avait été
prévu que ces autos tests soient
disponibles à la vente en grandes
surfaces mais finalement ils ne seront
disponibles que dans les pharmacies
seulement 1 des syndicats de pharmaciens
alerte sur le peu d'informations qu'ils
ont concernant l'encadrement de ces auto
test et puis aussi sur la faible
quantité de stocks qu'ils ont reçues il
faut dire que l état a acquis un certain
nombre d'autos tests afin de les mettre
en place dans les établissements
scolaires en vue de la rentrée prochaine
merci sommes abonnés en direct du stade
de france et le gouvernement qui tente
d'accélérer en état de cadence vaccinale
et adapte sa doctrine alors le
gouvernement n'est victime a vu place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités avec
nous pour en parler bastien lachaud
député est la fille de seine-saint-denis
pierre frédéric billets mer et l'air de
dreux et enfin jean lain la capelle
député européen est reine bourgeois re
bonsoir à tous les deux renshaw et 3
pardon merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vacciner vacciner vacciner
1 dit et écrit sur twitter le président
c'est l'obsession du moment sur le
terrain la campagne on l'a vu un
vaccination patine l'exemple du stade de
france méga centre qui a dû être fermée
hier une inactivité forcée faute de
doses une situation vous avez également
vécu à dreux c'est à frédéric bihet
racontez nous ah oui tout à fait j'ai
chanté hier sur tf1 parce que la
ministre pas dire une hache et a demandé
au maire de vacciner le dimanche alors
moi je veux bien belle fille née
dimanche a pas de problème sur le camp
n'a pas de dose pour le 8e dimanche
on ne peut pas le faire donc si vous
voulez c'était une forme aussi
d'agacement de dire nous sommes
interpellés en tant que maire à dreux
2021 c'est un million d'euros aux
vacciner toute l'agglomération
donc c'est colossal nous nous nous les
prendrons témoins pour me dire mais si
les maires vacciner de dimanche je veux
bien mais donnez moi des doses voilà
sans d'intervention de ces paniers
jouent alors on va essayer de creuser un
petit peu plus parce que c'est
évidemment intéressant ce que vous nous
dites et ça décrit une situation de
terrain qui tranche parfois avec les
effets peut-être d'annonce du
gouvernement bastien la chaux vous le
seine-saint-denis c'est votre
département vous connaissez bien ce
stade de france inaugurée en fanfare par
le gouvernement la semaine dernière
on vient d'entendre défectueux en raison
de la pénurie des vaccins comment
réagissent et habitants sur place
en fait les habitants eux ce qu'ils
demandent c'est pas vaccinodromes parce
que dans le vaccinodromes déjà il est
ouvert très largement beaucoup plus
largement que la seine-saint-denis où on
est déjà un département qui a eu ce
problème là au début de la vaccination
l'essentiel des rendez-vous qui est des
prix sur internet été pris par des parts
des parisiens qui n'avaient plus de
place à paris et qui faisait prendre je
vais pas dire prendre la place des des
habitants de seine-saint-denis mais en
tout cas les habitants de
seine-saint-denis ne fait pas bander
rendez-vous aujourd'hui on a besoin que
les centres de proximité tourne à plein
régime
et le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
centres de proximité ne tourne pas à
plein régime
moi j'ai eu et j'ai vu les chiffres de
la semaine dernière de vaccination en
seine saint denis il y a moins de
vaccination en seine-saint-denis la
semaine dernière qu'il ya quinze jours
et s'éteint c'est un vrai problème c'est
à dire qu'on nous dit la vaccination la
vaccination le problème il n'ya pas les
doses les doses ne sont pas là moi j'ai
interpellé le préfet le préfet m'a dit
mais c'est normal qu'il y ait moins de
premières vaccinations parce que les
deux partent pour les deuxièmes
vaccination dit bon c'est assez logique
et la réalité c'est que moi j'ai eu donc
quand on a repris les chiffres de la
semaine et les premières injections et
le deuxième sélection sont en baisse
donc où sont tes dose s'il n'y a pas de
dose le gouvernement doit le dire et ne
doit pas nous dire on accélère on
accélère en accélère alors que les deux
ne sont pas là le gouvernement a doit
assumer le fait qu' il n'a pas mis en
place la politique nécessaire depuis un
an pour avoir un vaccin français qu'ils
soient produits en france et qui permet
de vacciner
donc aujourd'hui on est dans les mains
des grandes entreprises du de pharmacie
et la réalité c'est que ils en ont rien
à faire de nous teaser fournit les
américains aux priorités et des
européens passeront après peut-être un
jour s'il reste des doses et ça c'est
totalement inacceptable c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement parce que
le président annonce sur twitter
produire produire produire
la seule chose que nous sommes en
capacité de faire aujourd'hui à cause de
son incurie c'est de mettre en flacon
des dessins animés des vaccins de pfizer
et encore nous ne sommes même pas sûrs
que les doses qui seront mises en place
qu'on en france serviront aux français
j'attends d'un véritable problème
oui les gens là la capelle votre
réaction quand vous entendez ces deux
élus de terrain nous dire voilà séméga
sont on est obligés de les arrêter de
toute façon faute de doses vous vous
dites bon ça va aller mieux il ya
johnson and johnson qui arrive ou voilà
vous perdez un petit peu espoir où je
vous dis quand même que c'est une ronde
pour la sixième puissance mondiale
récemment nous sommes la risée du monde
l'union européenne la risée du monde
l' oms avait trouvé inacceptable notre
rythme de vaccination
mais au sein de l'union européenne il ya
encore plus mauvais que tout le monde
sait la france puisque moi j'ai les
chiffres devant moi nous sommes 9e
proportionnellement par rapport aux
populations sur injection la première
dose nous sommes 21e sur la deuxième
dose ce qui est vraiment inacceptable
mais depuis le départ on a vu qu'il a vu
mais on n'a pas le permis bateau et
c'est un petit peu ça depuis début
d'ailleurs de la crise sanitaire avec le
gouvernement français
on a été très mauvais parce qu'on est co
responsable de cette négociation qui a
mené union européenne qui a voulu être
plus forte que les autres et qui a tant
donné
oui oui tout à fait on vous entend très
bien parfaitement revient j'ai
l'impression que j'en la capelle
nous entends plus nous on l'entendait
parfaitement si on peut lui faire passer
ce message
pierre frédéric billets l'illustration
aussi peut-être de cette navigation à
vue comme nous l'expliqué jean lain la
capelle aujourd'hui on décide que
finalement il y aura un espacement de
deux doses un antre pour l'évêque
seither et modern art de 28 jours à 42
jours alors qu'au départ c'était non ces
changements de cas vous vous les
comprenez on se dit ah bah ça on prend
l'exemple anglais on navigue à vue mais
voilà il faut s'adapter ou ça va
augmenter la défiance delà de la
population ce type de décision alors qui
est vrai c'est qu'on voit bien que
l'état trou est fait de trouver des
solutions pour avoir des primo vacciner
en plus grand nombre
la première salve a été de passer de 21
jours à 28 jours pour la seconde dose et
maintenant on passe de 28 jours à 42
jours
c'est aussi un débat scientifique
je comprends la volonté de l'état de
vouloir essayer d'élargir le spectre
cela étant c'est pas forcément très
rassurant pour les gens on se pose
beaucoup de questions on voit bien dans
notre faim de vaccination il ya deux
questions qui viennent
la première c est ce que vous avez della
sera donné car du finder ou autres est
une question c'est pourquoi
l'élargissement de cette bd entre les
deux doses ont coulé il ya beaucoup de
résistance de défiance de l'élite fort
ça ne suffit pas la tâche et on doit
faire nous son terrain face à des
demandes qui font l'élite il alors autre
illustration d'une certaine confusion ça
se passe en moselle mais ça explique
bien la situation lors des médecins de
moselle qui a exprimé son
incompréhension face à la décision de la
rs et de la préfecture de continuer à
vacciner avec l'astra zeneca alors que
la haute autorité de santé recommande de
ne plus utiliser ce vaccin trop peu
efficace contre le variant sud africain
qui sévit durement dans ce département
on a du mal à suivre tout de même
bastien la chaux que vous inspire c'est
petite confusion vous vous êtes tolérant
par rapport à ça vous trouvez ça
finalement impardonnable
part des autorités en fait ce que l'on
pouvait accepter il ya un an devient
beaucoup plus compliqué à accepter
aujourd'hui comment voulez vous que l'on
puisse accepter ce que décide ce
gouvernement alors que le gouvernement
n'a rien planifié n'a rien anticipé
c'est ça le problème
on ne lui demande pas d'être parfait
mais on lui demande d'anticiper et de ne
pas courir au jour le jour pour trouver
des solutions avec des bouts de ficelle
là aujourd'hui si on est au jour obligé
de d'élargir le délai entre les dodos
c'est uniquement parce qu'on n'a pas
assez de doses il fallait produire du
vaccin produit reproduire et on sait le
faire en plus c'est ça le pire c'est que
nous avons des capacités nous avons des
chercheurs nous avons des capacités de
production en forme s en de médicaments
et aujourd'hui on ne les a pas utilisés
on n'a rien fait et la voyez par exemple
on parle du vaccin mais ce qui est
essentiel aussi c'est les questions
traitement est bien le l'institut
pasteur de lille et travaille sur un
traitement depuis plusieurs mois et il
avait demandé 5 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir avancer sur ce traitement le
gouvernement n'a rien fait c'est lvmh
qui a dû le silence et on a dû refaire
appel le mécénat privé est là
aujourd'hui on découvre que ce vaccin
est très prometteur que le gouvernement
le place comme une des solutions d' donc
le gouvernement ne planifie pas le
gouvernement n'anticipe pas le
gouvernement court après la crise et
évidemment cela crée de la défiance pour
les français parce que il y encore un
mois on expliquait que si on élargit ses
les doses eh bien cela ne crée la
possibilité d'avoir des variants qui se
crée suite à la première injection et
que donc cela pouvait mettre en péril la
stratégie vaccinale est là aujourd'hui
on élargit des doses
moi je ne suis pas scientifique je ne
sais pas mais le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui peut-on faire confiance à la
parole du gouvernement et la parole du
gouvernement est totalement
décrédibilisée dévalorisé et c'est un
vrai problème parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin que les gens se fassent
vacciner parce que nous avons besoin de
l'immunité collective
mais comment voulez-vous dire aux gens
allez vous faire vacciner alors que le
tous les pays européens ont des
stratégies différentes sur l'astra
zeneca que de région du région à l'autre
nous ne faisons pas la même chose sur
l'utilisation de ceux de ce vaccin
bref aujourd'hui
le gouvernement met en péril la sortie
de crise tout simplement à cause de son
impréparation le gouvernement aussi qui
freinent des quatre fers quant au
spoutnik v berlin en négociations avec
la russie et clément beau de moody hier
qu en gros c'est un coup de
communication de la part de berlin votre
réaction gens là la capelle oui je vous
y retrouver excusez moi d'ailleurs pour
cette petite polémique un petit peu figé
mais vous vous entendez bien néanmoins
donc voilà écoutez je suis désolé mais
je suis à vous c'est le salut parlement
européen et vous comprenez bien qu'ici
tout ne fonctionne pas même vachement
bien vous en avez lu stressant
supplémentaires mais pour répondre à
votre question
madame en effet c'est finalement un peu
le préambule que je voulais tout à leur
exprimer
mais le gouvernement a tout raté depuis
le départ ce sera des givati nal je
parlais de cette négociation qui est un
véritable fiasco puisque le parlement
européen a souhaité la commission
européenne a souhaité qu'on comme qu'est
d'entrée le prix dans ces négociations
pour essayer de les meilleurs que les
autres bien finalement oui ils ont
acheté le vaccin parfois un peu moins
cher mais ils ont été livrés les
derniers parce que rien n'est ficelé
derrière dans le conte un commercial
même pas ce qui est le b à ba d'un
contrat commercial même pas les pdt de
retard ça c'était le premier point il a
été mauvais jeu par les français comme
qui ont été d'ailleurs bien moins bon
qu'un stand de leurs voisins européens
dans l'exécution opérationnelle
on n'a pas utilisé l'armé on l'avait
réclamé déjà il ya plusieurs mois
on finit par comprendre que l'armée peut
être utile est d'ailleurs maintenant
elle s'adonne d'hôpitaux vont être
mobilisés à sand équipe de soignants
militaire utilisée pour aujourd'hui si
le rattraper le retard terrible que le
gouvernement a pris et puis à cette
gestion de la pénurie
vous parliez d'alternative à nos
ruptures à nos vaccins qui aujourd'hui
est bien ne sont pas les livres et
approvisionne chez nous bien oui il ya
le spoutnik par exemple on pourrait
commander le spoutnik
on a le seul où tu as d'état du
gouvernement se fout de nous puisque
depuis mois de décembre en envoyer une
mission gouvernementale en russie et
depuis deux ans il ne se passe rien on
nous dit oui mais il ya un processus de
validation d'homologation alors en fait
pour valider astrazeneca ont validé
johnson and johnson faut valider freezer
il faut trois semaines
mais pour les russes il faut 12 mois
en fait on sent bien qu ici on se fout
de nous on sent bien que le gouvernement
est temps de fermer dans des pièges
idéologique
aujourd'hui de choisir le pragmatisme il
dans le dogmatisme le fait de la même
manière comme il l'avait fait
rappelez-vous sur la gestion des
frontières et il a effet se refusant de
suspendre l'ouverture en fin de support
l'ouverture des frontières en effet de
vol qui provenaient de la chine
il le fait pareil pour le brésil parce
que vous savez ce qui se passe au brésil
en ce moment il ya 4000 morts cinq jours
justement jamais venir pardonnez moi
les français qui ont découvert que des
avions faisait chaque jour la navette
avec le brésil je rappelle qu'au qu'au
brésil il y à plus de 330 milles mort du
co vide avec la propagation d'un variant
très inquiétant d'ailleurs dont on ne
sait pas bien s'il résiste aux vaccins
ou pas clairement pierre frédéric billet
il faudrait fermer les frontières comme
le préconisait d'ailleurs le
rassemblement national dès le début de
l'épidémie il faudrait en tout cas le
faire aujourd'hui fermée au moins ses
liaisons avec le brésil comme le fait le
portugal d'ailleurs alors j'allais
donner l'exemple du portugal mais
globalement effectivement on doit avoir
une politique plus plus défensive pour
une population
après je vous donnais l'état d'esprit
que je parte avec beaucoup d'élus locaux
c'est que l'on considère que nous et le
gouvernement nous sommes dans le même
bateau
donc nous sommes sollicités pour mettre
en place les centres de vaccination des
vaccinés drôme quand ils dépassent une
500 vaccins
donc on est tous dans le même bateau on
le fait pour les français pour la
population simplement il faut bien
comprendre qu'il faut nous laisser faire
et sur de vaccination les organise il
faut pas nous imposer d'octo libre à
tous chants il faut ne sait gérer les
rendez vous et surtout ce que j'invite
mois le gouvernement c'est d'être
transparent et clair on fait tous des
erreurs on fait tous des choses comme ça
mais il faut pas raconter des fadaises
ou français
quand je vois qu'on annonce une
accélération de la vaccination
tous les chiffres que je vois
aujourd'hui arrivées de la grève ce
n'est pas la réalité
donc on est là pour les français ont
fait le maximum pour nos populations
il faut nous laisser faire des solutions
locales sont souvent les meilleurs
d'ailleurs on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur l'un
deux thématiques comme le basque
vaccination mais nous on demande de la
transparence et de la clarté pas ce que
c'est
nous qui ne sommes les relais sur le
terrain auprès des populations qui font
inquiète donc je demande un petit peu de
calme soyons transparents et on fera bon
an mal an un bon travail avec les
français sur cette fermeture des
frontières parce que c'est inquiète
beaucoup de monde un ces variants et
notamment le brésilien avant de faire
réagir bastien millot écouter le
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
jean bêtisier baril qui donne une
explication justement ce n'est pas la
faute du gouvernement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a gardé ses lignes
parce que s'est imposée par le droit
le conseil d'état nous a dit tout des
ressortissants français et les résidents
en france devaient pouvoir continuer à
venir
au nom de la liberté de circulation
bastien à chaud c'est un droit la
liberté de circulation nous dit à jean
baptiste djebbari il faudrait vous les
supprimez céline d'avion aujourd'hui
écoutés déjà on a fait une erreur c'est
à dire qu'on a laissé venir le variant
britannique sur notre territoire
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que le
gouvernement n'a pas compris la leçon
n'a pas appris la leçon et nous risquons
la même chose avec le variant brésilien
qui est de ce que j'ai pu voir sur les
études scientifiques quelque chose de
largement pire encore que le variant que
le variant britannique
moi je j'ai eu dans ma circonscription
des ressortissants français qui ont été
bloqués à l'étranger pendant des mois au
début de la crise et personne ne se
soucie et le gouvernement en dernier ce
souci de les faire revenir et de les
rapatrier alors qu' il était en vacances
ils étaient coincés luan cgct on a dû
faire des pieds et des mains pour
pouvoir les faire les faire revenir
parce que les pauvres bougres été
complètement perdus à l'étranger
hélas la réalité c'est que moi je ne
sais pas qui qui monte dans ses avions
la vérité c'est que il faut les je ne
sais pas s'il faut fermer les lignes
encore une fois c'est un avis de
scientifiques mais ce qui est certain
c'est que ce que demandent les
scientifiques c'est que les gens soient
testés à l'arrivée pourquoi ne détestons
nous pas à l'arrivée ça ce quelque chose
de basique
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que l'on
peut venir en france sans aucun contrôle
il s'en est sans aucun test alors moi je
ne sais pas s'il ya tant de français que
ça au brésil vont nécessiter deux vols
quotidiens et donc près de
près de 600 places j'imagine vu la
taille des avions il fasse il ya six ans
français qui rentrent du brésil tous les
tous les jours donc peut-être que l'on
peut réduire le nombre de vols et
surtout ce qui est certain c'est que le
doit contrôler systématiquement et voir
imposer des 40 m
en grande bretagne il s'impose 14 jours
de quarantaine en france on arrive on a
un test pcr de 72 heures avant le vol
alors qu'on sait très bien que les 72
heures c'est pile le moment où si on est
contaminé le juste après le test eh bien
on est hyper contaminants au moment de
son arrivée en france sans symptômes
eh bien je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
n'impose pas des quarantaines pourquoi
on n'impose pas de passer des séjours à
l'hôtel loews hôtel sont vides en tout
cela permettrait de remplir les hôtels
et de faire fonctionner une économie sur
ce thème est pas trois réponses d'écouté
par mois ce fut hélas il est
symptomatique là aussi de l'état
d'esprit un petit peu de l'union
européenne vous l'avez partait de
bandits il ya un danger aujourd'hui qui
provient du brésil à 4000 morts par jour
4 liban par jour c'est à dire qu'il ya
un mort toutes les trois secondes en ce
moment au brésil qui meurent du variant
amazonien où les variants brésilien est
notamment beaucoup de gens qui 50 % des
morts au moins de 45 ans avec vraiment
on est en train de me c'est un variant
qui est difficilement maîtrisable et qui
touche manière très large
aujourd'hui la population que fait la
france est bien des portes grandes
ouvertes au mois de février la nadière
marine le pen avec la première à envoyer
une lettre écrite à à la semaine
nationale en demandant au gouvernement
de fermer des vols qui provenaient de la
chine
ils ne l'ont jamais fait il a fallu des
mois et des mois un an
on comprend enfin que la fermeture des
frontières ou la régulation des
frontières elle était de réguler et de
contrôler la circulation du virus est
bien là écoutez ça se reproduit une
nouvelle fois quand au portugal qui lui
a proposé à prix sa rentabilité peu
importe ce que décide l'union européenne
au moins quand tu gagnes après
sensibilité la france est encore en
baisse dans l'expectative en fait qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut servez les
vols a dit en provenance notamment du
brésil
et puis quand ça concerne en effet leurs
ressortissants il faut pouvoir les
isoler et les mettre en quarantaine sont
14èmes ce que nous n'avons jamais fait
aujourd'hui où provenait vous arrivez le
brésil avec un engagement sur l'honneur
et un test pcr vous entrez chez nous ça
n'est pas normal ça n'est pas normal
avec un virus aussi dangereux que celui
là on le sait qu'avoir de vains mots
anglais et bien les fronts
c'est qu'ils devraient être protégés
aujourd'hui quel gouvernement qui
devrait prendre sa solidité
et bien finalement n'y arrive pas on
nous a vendu une grande robe de la santé
une grande d'europe de la protection on
se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui bien ça
n'est pas le cas et maquereau est
responsable cela que tout ça très grave
parce qu'il a été élu par les français
pour qu'ils soient protégés et bien fait
tout le contraire pour des raisons
idéologiques pour des exemples
dogmatisme alors qu'on lui demandait de
pragmatique pierre frédéric bihet le mot
de la fin pour vous quand emmanuel
macron nous promet un plan de
réouverture d'ici la mi mai c'est à dire
quoi dans allez un petit mois vous y
croyez
écoutez en guise de conclusion je veux
dire deux choses le contrôle des
frontières est une chose importante
on est en plein confinement de l'autre
côté on met beaucoup de pression sur les
français pour que il respecte toutes les
règles et de l'autre côté on accueille
des gens qui d'être du président
ailleurs sans trop de contrôles on
comprenait que cette espèce de mécanique
à deux vitesses à peu un peu agacé les
français première chose et puis la
seconde chose c'est que il faut
absolument qu'on sorte de cette épisode
qui est quand même très malheureux
n'oublions pas que derrière cette crise
il y à des commerçants des restaurateurs
de l'emploi les gens qui sont en
détresse mentale qui font détresse
économique nous localement et de nos
petits bras on était de faire le maximum
pour les aider mais il faut offrir
aujourd'hui la lisibilité j'espère que
l'animé et les restaurants pourront
ouvrir jusqu'à 3 et des surnombres
dès qu'on aura un début de fin du tunnel
je vous assure que nos restaurateurs de
commerçants les chefs d'entreprise
il faut en pleine dépression moi ça
m'inquiète beaucoup la reprise va être
là j'espère un très rapidement mais moi
j'appelle aussi gouvernement à bien
réfléchir sur des messages qui vont
passer dans les prochains jours
vis-à-vis de nous chez notre petit
commerçant rien merci en tout cas tous
les trois à merci bastien la chope hier
à frédéric vié
et jenlain la capelle d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
tensions entre la russie et l'ukraine
l'armée craignait n'aurait commencé à
bombarder la banlieue de dawn y est
selon le maire de la ville le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne sera reçu demain
à l'otan et puis direction haïti au
lendemain de l'enlèvement de sept
religieux catholiques dont deux français
près de la capitale port au prince une
rançon d'un million de dollars et est
réclamée par les ravisseurs
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplôme ès on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il
n'ya pas intervenir on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dit aux nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez moscou préoccupé par
la situation en ukraine
l'armée craignait n'aurait commencé à
bombarder la banlieue de dawn y est
selon le maire de la ville
le bombardement a été effectué à la mi
journée à partir d'un véhicule de combat
d'infanterie avec un lance-roquettes
selon kiev depuis samedi deux militaires
ukrainiens auraient été tués dans des
combats avec les séparatistes du dombass
alors comment réagit de son côté la
russie la correspondance et moscou
d'antoine clairon les heurts meurtriers
continuent de se multiplier dans le
donbass sur cette fameuse ligne de
contact de soldats ukrainien morts
depuis samedi
et en face on rapporte des bombardements
dans plusieurs quartiers de donetsk dont
on ignore encore le bilan humain une
situation qui résulte de provocation de
la part de kiev
d'après le kremlin le dombass fait face
à une situation de non respect des
accords de minsk un nombre accru de
provocation de la part des forces armées
chrétiennes
en d'autres termes il ya des
provocations auxquelles répondent des
tirs de riposte
étant donné les tensions général le fait
qu'il n'y a pas de désescalade et que
les tensions sont très élevés de telles
provocations peuvent du jour au
lendemain faire plonger le conflit
ukrainien dans la guerre civile
voilà pourquoi nous ne cessons
d'exprimer notre préoccupation
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères rappelle lui qu'il s'agit
d'un conflit un train craignant survenue
à la suite d'un coup d'état et
disqualifie les récentes déclarations du
président lnsq canton ce moment les
représentants de l'administration de
zelensky déclare que kiev ne planifie
rien dans le donbass parce que kiev ne
peut pas faire la guerre à son propre
peuple ce n'est pas vrai
kiev après la soi disant révolution de
la dignité qui était en réalité un coup
d'état a attaqué son propre peuple même
depuis une guerre contre son propre
peuple
il traite la population du dombass de
terroristes alors que ces derniers n'ont
attaqué personne sur le reste du
territoire ukrainien sergueï lavrov a
aussi répété que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
la russie pouvait déplacer ses forces
armées où bon lui semble sur son
territoire et l inverse il dit
s'interroger sur le rôle des états unis
en ukraine
que ce soit via l'otan ou sous la forme
de dons d'équipements militaires et ce à
des milliers de kilomètres de son propre
territoire est les tensions entre
l'ukraine et la russie au coeur des
discussions demain à l'otan le chef de
la diplomatie ukrainienne est attendu
par le secrétaire de l'alliance
jens stoltenberg le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken est également
en visite à bruxelles jusqu'à jeudi pour
des consultations avec les alliés de
l'otan et des responsables européens
pourront parler nous sommes avec serge
par innove secrétaire de presse de
l'ambassade russe à paris bonsoir serge
pin up merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france la tension qui monte donc
1 à la frontière entre la russie et
l'ukraine valdimir poutine qui parle de
provocation dangereuse
pourquoi ce regain de tension selon vous
qui a rompu des accords de minsk bons
joueurs voyez vous la situation est
vraiment dangereuse mais pour la
comprendre faut revenir quand même un
peu en arrière revenir dans l'histoire
en 2014 tout début 2014 les trois
puissances européennes à savoir la
france l'allemagne et la pologne ont
contresigné l'accord entre le président
de l'époque victor ianoukovitch et
ladite opposition
un accord qui est passé dans la poubelle
moins de vingt quatre heures avant sa
signature le président a été destitué il
a dû quitter le pays et l'opposition à
monter un gouvernement des vainqueurs au
lieu de gouvernement de la cohésion
nationale sans que les garants dudit
accord ont leur mot à dire
presqu'un an plus tard en février 2015
les accords de minsk ont été signés les
accords dit
insc 2 puisque en fait c'était un
document qui s'intitulerait
officiellement l'ensemble de mesures
pour l'application des protocoles de
minsk
un autre document signé
quelques mois plus tôt également garanti
par la france l'allemagne et la russie
hélas nos partenaires occidentaux se
sont montrés incapables de venir un
médiateur honnête dans ce jeu et depuis
le début depuis 2015 donc l'ukraine
esquive l'application de dix accords de
misc dès son retour à kiev en fait et je
tiens à souligner tout particulièrement
que ce document de quelques pages
aujourd'hui tout le monde en parle mais
ça tourne à la folie des fois j'ai
l'impression que les gens qui en parlent
ne l'ont jamais vu quoi que ça ne fait
que deux trois pages grand maximum
d'ondés son retour à minsk et le
président prochain qu annoncé que cet
accord a été signé puisque le prennent
en avait besoin pour gagner du temps que
vous ferez d'ici un an nous serons un
état prospère tandis que dans basse
sombrera dans la misère vos enfants
iront à l'école tandis qu'ebay leur
série contre les cavs et cetera et
cetera et cetera
depuis l'ukraine a fait voter une
quantité de loi qui contredisent
directement les clauses de l'accord de
minsk notamment la loi sur l'éducation
qui a banni du système éducatif national
russe et la loi sur l'utilisation de
l'ukrainien en tant que langue langues
nationales tout ça ça contredit
directement les dits d'accord
il en est de même pour le retrait des
troupes et des armes lourdes de calibre
dépassant 100 mm de la zone de contact
ce qui n'a pas été respecté vous parliez
serge par les neuf des pays occidentaux
les états unis en tout cas montrent
leurs muscles et envoie deux navires de
guerre en mer noire le secrétaire d'état
américain à la défense
anthony blinken sera de retour dès hier
à bruxelles cette semaine pour des
discussions notamment sur la situation
dans le donbass clairement est ce que
vous craignez une escalade
oui on peut l'attendre on peut
l'attendre et vraiment c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser qu'est ce que font
les navires américains à des milliers de
milles marins de leur territoire au lieu
de se poser la question pourquoi les
troupes russes se déplace sur notre
propre territoire
clairement quand la russie dit qu'elle
n'est pas une menace pour l'ukraine pour
les gens qui seraient sceptiques
qu'est-ce que vous répondriez pourquoi
veux tu ont estimé que la russie soit
une menace
la russie est un des garants des accords
de paix signés à minsk
il ya six ans la russie n'a jamais
agressé l'ukraine secrétaire général de
l'otan en tout cas recevra demain le
ministre ukrainien on disait des
affaires étrangères à bruxelles
l'ukraine qui appelle l'otan accélérer
son adhésion pour envoyer un signal à la
russie c'est une ligne rouge pour moscou
vous savez ce n'est pas un mois de
prendre ses décisions mais effectivement
on devrait se poser la question les
exercices militaires de l'otan prévus en
ukraine à partir de mois de mai à quel
point correspond ça à un autre point
notre ami né à des hackers de minsk qui
prévoit notamment le retrait de toute
force militaire étranger du territoire
national alors la france elle a réagi
via un communiqué de presse du ministère
des affaires étrangères
ça date de vendredi dernier je vous
propose de l'écouter avant de vous faire
réagir la france considère important et
urgent que la russie puisse apporter de
manière transparente notamment par les
mécanismes prévus à l'ouest c'est eux
des clarifications sur le cadre et les
motivations de ces mouvements
nous soutenons la position de retenue et
de responsabilité affiché dans ce
contexte par les autorités ukrainiennes
la france poursuivra ses efforts
diplomatiques en lien étroit avec
l'allemagne dans le cadre du format
normandie afin de parvenir à la pleine
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk ces
efforts restent indispensables pour
parvenir à une désescalade détention n
résolution de la crise ukrainienne la
france est supposé est médiatrice dans
ce conflit est ce qu'elle s'y prend de
la bonne manière
je crois que non il en est de même avec
l'accord signé en 2014 entre utah
ianoukovitch et l'opposition
je crois que le comportement actuel de
l'ukraine suis de ce fait que les
garants de l'accord de 2014 n'ont pas
réagi à sa violation
aujourd'hui le cren se croient tout
permis y compris la violation des
acteurs de musc
encore une fois je tiens à souligner que
les troupes russes se déplacent à
l'intérieur du territoire us tandis que
les troupes ukrainienne quoique en
ukraine se trouve aujourd'hui là où il
ne devrait pas être en application des
accords de manière c'est-à-dire dans la
zone de 50 km de la ligne de contrôle de
contact dernière question sur ce thème
avant de passer à un autre thème
emmanuel macron doit rencontrer son
homologue ukrainien vomir zelensky les
deux présidents qui discuteront du
déploiement récent de forces russes
après de près de la frontière avec
l'ukraine
comment est perçu 7 heures rencontre en
russie vous savez c'est une rencontre en
deux chefs d'état nabe su la russie n'a
pas son mot à dire on va regarder les
résultats mais nous constatons que
vladimir zelensky multiplient ces
derniers temps son agitation sur le plan
international multiplie des contacts
afin de s'attirer de son côté le maximum
de soutien occidental qui n'est pas
toujours
disons très honnête très très juste
alors autres grands sujets d'actualité
combien la crise sanitaire et la
vaccination avec le vaccin russe foot
nick v qui attend toujours sa validation
à l'europe reprennent du médicament pas
avant fin juin si on comprend bien
comment vous expliquez vous cette
lenteur vous savez c'est pas nous à
l'expliquer dans le monde
où nous vivons aujourd'hui heureusement
aucun états au moins pour l'instant quoi
que les états unis ont fait beaucoup de
progrès là-dessus ne peut imposer un
autre état souvent l'utilisation ou la
non utilisation de tel ou tel produit
la russie n'impose rien la russie
propose le produit que nous avons un
vaccin ce pique nique à savoir nous en
avons deux autres mais c'est le football
qui est produite en quantité au jury qui
s'est avérée efficace fiable et
relativement peu coûteux si l'europe on
à l'intérêt tant mieux sinon nous ne
cherchons pas à nous imposer
il ya souvent un argument qui revient la
capacité de production de la russie de
ce vaccin qui seraient moindres a
notamment selon la france
est ce que c'est le cas mais
effectivement nous avons la possibilité
de lancer sa production ensemble c'est
pour ça qu'une délégation de
spécialistes français s'est rendu à
moscou fin automne 2020 pour étudier la
production de
de ce vaccin les contacts entre
spécialistes ont été plutôt assez
positive maintenant nous attendons la
validation de notre vaccin par l'agencé
européenne
en tout cas il ya d'autres pays qui sont
plus audacieux
l'allemagne en fait partie elle a ouvert
donc des discussions avec la russie sur
spoutnik v clément bonin le secrétaire
d'état européens a déploré un coup de
communication il estimé que la décision
était liée à la tenue outre-rhin des
prochaines législatives
qu'est ce que vous répondez en tant que
plus quand vous entendez ça écoute
écoute et si les personnalités
politiques à l'occident cherche à
utiliser le vaccin spoutnik vais pour ce
faire des points dans leur jeu politique
intérieure cela ne peut que prouver la
bonne qualité de notre médicament dont
nous ne pouvons qu on être fier alors
emmanuel macron lui ville va plus loin
il y voit carrément un outil de
propagande je vous propose d'écouter le
chef d'état français à la sortie du
dernier conseil européen c'était le 25
mars
l'europe et les chiffres qui ont été
citées par votre collègue tout à l'heure
le monde et le seul compte le seul
continent qui en plus exporte ses deux
seuls continents du monde libre qui a
une vraie stratégie vaccinale est une
vraie diplomatie vaccinale pas pour
aller faire du chantage à tel ou tel
pays mais pour dire c'est un engagement
international qui est le nôtre et donc
faut être très clair nous sommes face à
une guerre mondiale d'un nouveau genre
face notamment aux attaques aux
velléités de déstabilisation russe
chinoise d' influence par le vaccin
d'influencé par le vaccin à un volonté
de déstabilisation les mots sont forts
emmanuel macron accuse clairement la
russie est ce qu'il ya des raisons vous
savez ce n'est pas un diplomate de
commenter le discours d'un chef d'état
de son accréditation dont je ne peux que
répéter ce que je viens de dire tout à
l'heure la russie ne cherche à faire
chanter personnes la russie n'impose pas
son vaccin
la russie ne refuse son exportation pour
des prétextes politiques ou autres
la russie propose la coopération
sur ce plan là il la propose depuis
longtemps en tant que diplomate vous
avez peut-être quand même un avis sur
cette division qui commencent à poindre
enfin ça fait d'ailleurs déjà quelques
semaines
en europe on n'est pas forcément
d'accord notamment sur ce le foot nick v
qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette division
selon vous sur l'état de l'europe
aujourd'hui vous savez des fois les
héros p1 ont du mal à s'entendre entre
eux c'est naturel lorsqu'on est 27 déjà
à 2 parfois il ya des mésententes à
trois ça devient encore plus compliqué à
27 j'imagine même pas à quel point ça
doit être l'enfer de trouver un
compromis qui conviendrait à tout le
monde
heureusement je ne suis pas un homme
politique européen
dernière petite question ça concerne
l'école à la maison formidable école à
la maison l'enquète sur le plantage un
du site centre national d'enseignement à
distance le fameux cned
jean michel blanquer a immédiatement
dénoncé les attaques je suis venu de
l'étranger citant même la russie on
appris hier que selon l' enquête des
ordinateurs chinois et russes ont bien
été utilisés pour viser mais surtout pas
de conclusion active 1 on apprend que ça
ne serait pas forcément des russes même
si ce sont des ordinateurs russe votre
réaction à ce réflexe de viser les
russes dès qu'il ya un piratage quelque
part je vous dirais même plus je suis
presque certain que ce sont mes gosses
ils sont capables à n'importe quoi pour
ne pas faire leurs cours ça doit être ça
sérieux pour être sérieux dans tout ce
qui se passe au niveau des de
l'informatique c'est un peu la magie
personne ne sera vous expliquer 99% de
la population sommes comme vous et moi
nous ne comprenons pas ce qui se passe
au moment où on appuie une touche où on
fait bouger le curseur sur l'écran
à l'intérieur de cette machine magique
nous avons bon dialogue entre la france
et la russie au niveau des spécialistes
sur les questions de la cybersécurité et
je crois que
il ya des raisons viable est valable de
considérer qu' il ya un problème c'est à
eux d'en parler merci l'ambassade russe
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france hommage aux héros russes de la
conquête spatiale youri gagarine premier
homme visiter l'espace c'était il ya 60
jours 60 ans jour pour jour
à cette occasion venir comptines s'est
déplacé sur le site d'atterrissage du
cosmonaute eagles en russie 700 km de
moscou un mémorial a été édifié puis le
président russe a rendu hommage à youri
gagarine lors d'une visio conférence au
cours de laquelle il est revenu sur les
objectifs ruches dans l'espace la russie
doit selon lui rester une grande
puissance dans la conquête spatiale
21e siècle la russie doit maintenir son
statut de puissance nucléaire et spatial
l'industrie spatiale est directement
liée à la défense ceux ci un swing
impôts c'est notre devoir de veiller à
ce que notre travail dans l'enclos
paroissial continue aujourd'hui d'être à
la hauteur c'est ce que les pionniers de
l'ex-prison est longtemps opposée en
haïti sept religieux catholiques dont 5
haïtien et deux français ont été enlevés
hier une enquête a été ouverte pour
enlèvement et séquestration en bande
organisée le kidnapping et eu lieu près
de la capitale port au prince quatre
prêtre et une religieuse haïtien ainsi
qu'à une religieuse et un prêt de
français ont été enlevés alors qu'ils se
rendaient sur le lieux saints est les
ravisseurs ont fait savoir qu'ils
exigeaient une rançon d'un milliard de
dollars et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec jacques léon emile président
de l'association haïti mémoires et
cultures bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france première question est ce que ces
enlèvements par des gangs et sont
monnaie courante
haïti bonsoir
stéphanie de moore effectivement c'est
ça fait 20 ans que l'industrie de l'
enlèvement fonctionne en haïti je suis
obligé de dire l'industrie de
l'enlèvement parce que c'est devenu une
vanne une banalité
alors avec des périodes plus ou moins
intense mais aujourd'hui l'intensité
accrue et au point de s'en prendre à des
gens d'église et surtout ce qui était
exceptionnel exceptionnel c'est qu'on
s'en prenne à des étrangers
la première la première réflexion que ça
m'inspire c'est de vous dire que d'après
aider en s'en prenant à l'étranger aux
étrangers ce sera peut-être peut-être
hélas a souhaité que ce sera l'amorcé
d'une solution que la communauté
internationale prenne conscience de ce
qui se passe en haïti et peut-être que
ça mènera des réactions je n'en sais
rien pour l'instant je me contente de
vous dire ça la précision que je peux
vous apporter concernant les élèves et
les enlèvements
c'est que ce week-end en 24 heures il ya
eu près d'une douzaine d'enlèvement en
plus offert au total en comptant ce que
vous venez de citer
et parmi les six autres six ou sept
autres en l enlèvement qui aurait lieu
celui d'un médecin chirurgien
orthopédiste celui d'un ancien grand
maître d'une grande loge de la grande
loge d'haïti du grand orient de france
est bref et un certain nombre d'autres
personnes de la famille des personnes
qui ont été les sept personnes qui a été
enlevé voilà c'est ça y tisser ce qui
est enfin de se passer de façon
dramatique qui ce n'est pas
une thèse religieuse un crime religieux
c'est un truc crime crapuleux il demande
je le rappelle un million de dollars de
rançons sont nés dans un van du
crapuleux et rien à voir avec des cibles
catholique en particulier comme vous
dites en l1 du crapuleux
n'importe qui peut être enlevé quel que
soit son statut
récemment j'ai des amis qui ont été
enlevées qui hélas qui heureusement s'en
sont bien tirés
il y a quelques années même presque
vingt ans j'ai eu quelqu'un de ma
famille qui a été enlevé et qui depuis
grâce à l'entreprise dans laquelle elle
travaillait sa rançon a été payée et la
quitter haïti
voilà ce qui est en train de se passer
et donc c'est ça aura certaines
conséquences j'ai envie de dire c'est
affreux j'ai envie de dire que ça aura
certaines conséquences heureusement
j'espère que la communauté
internationale j'insiste comprennent que
la situation est très grave parce que si
vous voulez le la première chose que
cela peut entraîner va certainement
entraîner c'est qu'il ya une fuite des
ressortissants haïtiens qui quittent le
pays
et comment vont ils essayer de quitter
le pays parce qu'on appelle les boat
people c'est à dire s'embarquer prendre
en gal s'engager sur des embarcations de
fortune
vous essayez de gagner les bahamas ou la
côte de l'afld la côte-d les côtes de
floride est peut-être là il y aura
vraiment une prise de conscience en ce
qui concerne ce gros drames humains que
vous constituez les boat people et
surtout là je me tourne vers les états
unis
parce que les états unis prendront
conscience que si leurs côtes sont mille
sont utilisés comme lieu d'asile par les
uns et par les haïtiens même s'il l'est
refouleront mais vous n'avez peut-être
pas connu ces événements en 1994 après
le coup d'état du général cédera contre
le président aristide des haïtiens au
kit hermas par des boat people et il ya
eu des haïtiens venir mourir sur les
côtes de la floride ça a poussé les
états unis à réagir ou destituer les
dictateurs en place voilà peut-être
voilà pourquoi je me permets de dire
qu'il ya peut-être une ébauche de prise
de conscience
évidemment ce n'est pas une solution que
l'on souhaite mais que voulez vous qu'on
fasse aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait le
fait que ces gangs soient de plus en
plus puissants c'est qu'ils sont souvent
soutenus pour certains par les
politiques eux mêmes soutenus par les
politiques eux mêmes et surtout que la
police est infesté et corrompu et que la
police n'est pas motivée pour intervenir
et qu'au sein même de la police
il ya des gens qui renseigne les gangs
parce que c'est de cette question de
corruption tout bêtement
j'invite juge dit tout bêtement mais
c'est quand même dramatique la police
intervient sans conviction et au sein
même de la police ya des espions au
service de ces gangs puisque ces gangs
paye
vous avez dit le montant de la rançon un
million de dollars entre autres il ya eu
d'autres sommes peut-être pas
équivalente ce montant là mais qui ont
été payées et à chaque fois vous vous
doutez bien que ça a été distribué
redistribuées donc tout le monde a été
pardon arrosé un peu ce qui devait
l'être
ça pose la question justement faut-il
payer ces rançons c'est toujours délicat
comme comme question là je n'ai pas la
réponse malheureusement je n'ai pas la
réponse
ce que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
quand en ce qui concerne les étrangers
les russes en l'occurrence des
ressortissants français
à mon avis à mon avis mais je je je dis
peut-être ya peu de chances qu'on attend
à leur vie parce qu'ils savent que si
les gangs savent que s'ils s'en prennent
ressortissants étrangers la conséquence
peut être beaucoup plus lourde pour eux
parce que la dépression peuvent être
faites sur le sud près peuvent être
faites sur le gouvernement sous les gens
en place
donc voilà c'est c'est difficile de
répondre
moi je ne vais pas mettre dans la
position d'un leader d'un lecteur de
polars qui va vous répondre
il faut pas céder il faut pas payer je
n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien
l'important pour les gens c'est de
sauver la vie c'est de sauver la vie de
leurs proches donc payer ou pas c'est ce
qu' ils s'élançaient il faudra aller
aller vers une solution surtout qu'on
récupère les otages
en pleine vie merci beaucoup
jacques léon emile d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
de la france les autorités ont
finalement choisi d'allonger le délai
entre les deux injections de vaccin 13h
et modern art pour tenter de vacciner
plus et puis direction l'angleterre qui
renoue un peu plus encore avec un
sentiment de liberté celle de ce soir en
terrasse ou de faire du shopping
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous imposer
comme un espoir français du tennis
fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le jambon moi j'ai un autre combat
on ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
la sphère archers gosses comment ce
family office at il réussi à provoquer
un nouveau vent de panique sur les
marchés mais aussi des pertes massives
pour plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé bon nombre de banques
à suivre monsieur c'est quelque chose
qui nous a emmenés dans une catastrophe
en 2007 et en 2008
tous les trucs et crédit ficelé goldman
sachs les morgan stanley était
évidemment pas au courant les uns des
autres quartiers gosses avaient autant
d'engagements à droite à gauche et c'est
en principe de l'opacité de la chose je
peux l'annoncer dès maintenant vous
aurez des archers gosses en x 10
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dole à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui vous voyez il ya énormément
de français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
veulent plus aller voter puisque vous
parlez de ce nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans un rassemblement on
a du mal à comprendre l'idée d'une
candidature communiste je ne souhaite
pas que dès maintenant au new deal et
bien vous n'avez pas le droit de
présenter votre candidature de quel
droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire ça
laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 12 avril
nouvelle étape dans la vaccination
toutes les personnes âgées de 55 ans et
plus ils sont désormais éligibles
elles recevront l'astra zeneca où le
petit nouveau johnson & johnson livrés à
partir d'aujourd'hui les autorités qui
finalement choisi d'allonger le délai
entre les deux injections de pfizer et
de modern à une manière de vacciner plus
alors que certains vaccinodromes ont été
mis à l'arrêt faute de doses
l'angleterre elle a déjà vacciné 60 % de
sa population avec la première dose et
renou un peu plus encore avec la liberté
celle de s'asseoir en terrasse ou de
faire du shopping
grâce à une campagne vaccinale réussi
qui semble faire défaut à l'un de ces
derniers jours le pays souffre d'une
pénurie de sérum et voit une
recrudescence de cas positifs
[Musique]
le sénat a donné son feu vert à
l'instant pour un amendement concernant
la loi sur le séparatisme qui donnerait
au préfet le pouvoir de s'opposer à
l'ouverture d'un établissement scolaire
privé cela alors qu'une école musulmane
albertville fait polémique
le président a l'air de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes enjoint les
autorités à empêcher cette installation
le préfet de savoie s'élève lui aussi
pour un projet démesuré et séparatisme
le tribunal administratif avait ordonné
au maire d'albertville de délivrer le
permis de construire de cette école
privée musulmane à laquelle des lieux
est opposé
aux etats unis donald trump refait
parler de lui l'ancien président
américain s'en est pris aux chefs des
républicains au sénat qu'il a tenus
responsables de l'attaquant janvier
dernier du capitole invité d'honneur
d'une réunion des donateurs donald trump
s'est aussi attribué le mérite d'avoir
développé un vaccin contre le coc vide
il devrait s'appeler trump sign at il
ajouté
mais
[Musique]
objectif du gouvernement face à la crise
du coc vie d'un déconfinement mi-mai
lors pour tenir cette ligne la cadence
vaccinale est supposé accéléré pour plus
de précision on retrouve tout de suite
en direct au mas bonnet devant le stade
de france transformée en vaccinodromes
un bon soir thomas la campagne de
vaccination où en est on
on est passé du nombre record de 510
milles injection vendredi dernier à 100
milles ce dimanche alors c'est quand
même plus que le dimanche précédent mais
à titre d'illustration le stade de
france transformée en vaccinodromes
était fermée hier faute de doses faute
de personnel on n'est pas encore sûr le
rythme 7 jours sur 7 souhaitée par le
président de la république
en tout cas en ce qui concerne assez
vaccinodromes il faut rappeler que le
principe même de vaccinodromes elle
avait d'abord été écartée par le
ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qui a donc finalement
changer de braquet mais pour s'assurer
de l'efficacité de ces immenses centres
de vaccination il va falloir compter sur
un approvisionnement important en
matière de doses de vaccins et thomas
pour accélérer et justement le rythme le
gouvernement on va bientôt pouvoir
s'appuyer sur un nouveau sérum celui de
johnson and johnson
il sera disponible à partir de ce
mercredi en france 200 mille doses
devrait arriver dans le courant de la
semaine selon les autorités sanitaires
avantage important pour le calendrier
fixé par le gouvernement
ce vaccin ne nécessite qu'une seule
injection cela va permettre de vacciner
davantage de personnes surtout que
depuis ce lundi depuis aujourd'hui
la vaccination est ouverte pour toutes
les personnes de plus de 55 ans mais
face aux craintes de pénurie oliveira a
également annoncé l'espacement des deux
injections nécessaires pour les vaccins
à arn messagers l'espacement va passer
de 28 à 42 jours à partir de mercredi
présentée comme une évolution des
connaissances scientifiques cet
aménagement va surtout permettre de
vacciner davantage et autres nouveautés
thomas de ce lundi la mise sur le marché
en fin des autotests après de longs mois
d'hésitations
oui il était temps la france faisait
exception dans ce domaine parce que ces
auto test était déjà largement répandu
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
ils sont donc disponible maintenant en
france depuis ce lundi pour les
personnes de plus de 15 ans initialement
il avait été prévu que ces autos tests
soient disponibles en grandes surfaces
finalement ils ne sont disponibles que
dans les pharmacies seulement des
syndicats de pharmaciens alerte sur le
peu d'informations qu'ils possèdent
concernant l'encadrement de ces auto
test et puis aussi sur les faibles
quantités qu'ils ont reçu ces derniers
jours il faut dire qu'une grande partie
de ces autos tests ont été acquis par
l'état qui souhaite les inclure dans les
établissements scolaires en vue de la
rentrée prochaine
merci thomas bonnin en direct du stade
de france le vexin johnson and johnson
est donc disponible en france est le 4e
200 mille doses qui doivent être livrés
à compter d'aujourd'hui par johnson la
filiale européenne du groupe
pharmaceutique américain
alors quelles sont les particularités de
ce nouveau venu le johnson and johnson
éléments de réponse en images
deux cent mille doses du vaccin johnson
johnson seront livrés les premières
arriveront en france avec une semaine
d'avancé dès ce lundi 12 avril contre le
19 avril initialement
d'après les annonces du ministre de la
santé dans les colonnes du journal du
dimanche selon les résultats des essais
cliniques
ce vaccin ne serait efficace qu'à 85 %
contre les formes graves du coït 19 le
sérum et efficace à 66% pour prévenir
les formes modérées à sévères de la
maladie
c'est moins que les vaccins de pfizer
biotech et moderna
cependant ces deux ces roms ont été
testés cliniquement alors que les
différents variant du virus n'était pas
encore connue le vaccin johnson and
johnson ne nécessite qu'une seule
injection
un avantage logistique il peut être
conservé trois mois dans des
réfrigérateurs à température standard ce
qui facilite sa distribution
l'agencé européenne des médicaments a
lancé une étude sur des liens possibles
entre ce vaccin est l'apparition de
caillots sanguins
après que quatre dont un mortel ont été
recensées pour le moment aucun lien de
causalité n'a été établie selon
l'autorité américaine de régulation
le laboratoire johnson and johnson
étudie l'effet de deux doses au lieu
d'une seule jusqu'à présent des
chercheurs ont émis des réserves sur
l'efficacité d'une seconde dose d essais
ont également été lancées sur les 12 17
ans est la crise sanitaire et ses
nombreuses conséquences notamment sur
les étudiants à lyon hier des étudiants
en art ont investi l'opéra pour dénoncer
leurs conditions de vie actuelles
ils réclament le retrait de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage des
revendications qui s'inscrivent dans les
langues nationales d'occupation des
lieux culturels
oui car vélo avec médiers ski fis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nouvelle action coup-de-poing l'opéra de
lyon déjà occupée par des contestataires
ce dimanche en fin d'après midi une
cinquantaine de personnes ont profité
d'une assemblée générale pour se
faufiler dans un amphithéâtre objectif
de ces étudiants en art fair entendre
leur voix sur leurs conditions de vie
actuelles
alors ce qui vient de se passer c'est
que avec les occupent un de l'eau est
occupante de l'opéra on vient de rentrer
à l'intérieur par l'entrée des artistes
et on vient de prendre l'amphithéâtre
qu'on avait pas jusqu'à maintenant voilà
on a profité d'une ag d'une assemblée
générale c'était important de réaliser
une action un peu importante avec de la
visibilité pour atteindre là qu'on
puisse parler de nos revendications que
ce soit celle pour nos conditions de
d'occupation à l'opéra et pour la lutte
en général coordonnée avec d autres
lieux culturels occupé en france depuis
un mois ces étudiants multiplient ce
type d'action ils se disent découragés
par l'absence de progrès dans les
négociations avec la direction pour
l'amélioration de leur quotidien
malgré cette mobilisation il constate un
manque d'écouté des décisionnaires
on a entamé des négociations n'a jamais
été entendu par la direction
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous a proposé un
abaissement des jauges et on va on nous
a complètement pas du tout laissé la
possibilité de faire autrement et il se
trouve que on sent ici il ya des
possibilités de s'arranger autrement et
c'est pour ça qu'on en est venu à faire
une action non violente en s'emparant de
l'amphithéâtre ici on se dit qu'il faut
absolument qu'on tienne qu'on résiste et
qu'on ait des lieux
de calme pour s'organiser et pour se
faire entendre encore plus une action
qui s'est déroulée pacifiquement et sans
dégradation l'occupation de l'opéra à
lyon par des étudiants en art s'inscrit
dans le mouvement national qui vise à
s'emparer des lieux culturels
leurs revendications sont identiques
prolongation de l'année blanche pour les
intermittents réouverture des lieux de
culture mais aussi retrait de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
sollicités régulièrement sur la reprise
des activités du secteur
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot ne s'est engagé sur aucune date
pour le moment en angleterre à présent
en retour à une vie presque nomma normal
près univers confiné regardez ces images
en direct yvan un truc que nous replacer
le moral il faut bien lire les anglais
en direct de londres les anglais ont
renoué ce matin avec ce sentiment de
liberté celle de s'asseoir en terrasse
comme on le voit sur ces images en
direct ou de faire du shopping
les terrasses sont donc plein dans la
capitale britannique l'amélioration de
la situation sanitaire permet au pays de
se dé confiné peu à peu plus tôt plus le
passé d'ailleurs grâce à donc cette
campagne de vaccination réussi retour
donc à une vie presque normale
[Musique]
[Rires]
de l'autre côté de la manche il y a
comme un air de vie d'avant à londres
profitez d'un café ou d'une pinte à
l'extérieur est de nouveau autorisé
après un hiver confiner les britanniques
retrouve les plaisirs de la vie
réouverture des terrasses des pubs et
restaurants mais aussi des commerces
dits non essentiels salon coiffure salle
de sport bibliothèque mmo un
assouplissement des restrictions
accueilli avec soulagement
nous étions revenus avant le 2è
confinement nous étions revenus pour une
petite visite donc c'est agréable de
revenir maintenant est de revoir tout le
monde beaucoup plus de gens en voyant
tour ouvrir à nouveau c'est juste
agréable d'être de retour honnêtement
côté professionnel la reprise de
l'activité constitue une véritable
résurrection
c'est un sentiment tellement agréable
d'ouvrir à nouveau ce portail est de
pouvoir accueillir autant de visages
souriants cela faisait longtemps que
nous attendions cela nous avons été
fermé pendant trois mois
et oui on sent vraiment que c'est un bon
jour cela a été dur
oxford street l'artère la plus
commerçante d'europe et ses 300 magasins
ne désemplissent pas et les commerçants
sont impatients nous avons une clientèle
locale exceptionnelle et très fidèle qui
tient vraiment à ce que les commerçants
l'essentiel rouvre et nous savons grâce
à l'expérience déconfinement précédent
que nous serions très occupée d'elle au
top départ
nous avons très hâte dans un premier
temps les salles des restaurants les
hôtels les salles de spectacle et les
stades vont rester fermés pour le
premier ministre britannique
cette nouvelle étape du déconfinement
est l'occasion de relancer une économie
qui a particulièrement souffert
je suis sûr que ce sera un énorme
soulagement pour les propriétaires
d'entreprises fermées depuis si
longtemps et pour tous les autres c'est
l'occasion de recommencer à faire
certaines des choses que nous aimons et
qui nous ont manqué un déconfinement
rendue possible par une campagne de
vaccination particulièrement efficace
depuis son lancement au mois de décembre
dernier les chiffres sont sans appel
près de 60 % des britanniques ont déjà
reçu une première dose de sérum si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent
la prochaine étape du déconfinement aura
lieu le 17 mai prochain
elle elle mène de son côté a franchi le
seuil des 3 millions d'infections la
chancelière angela merkel s'est
prononcée pour un confinement assez
brefs afin d'endiguer la troisième vague
le pays qui a entamé des discussions
avec la russie pour l'achat du vaccin
spoutnik v et précision de peter oliver
notre correspondant rtl berne a traqué
le ministre de la santé allemand a
déclaré en fin de semaine dernière que
l'allemagne négocierait son propre
approvisionnement en ce tout l'hiver une
fois le feu vert de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments obtenus
si l'allemagne doit négocier un accord
propre parce que le programme d'achat
commun européen ne s'applique pas aux
vaccins ce pique nique v pour le moment
cette annonce a également suscité des
commentaires en france selon le ministre
français des affaires étrangères il
s'agit d'un coup de publicité visant à
rassurer les marchés locaux avant il y
as c'est vrai des élections en septembre
et pour lui yann c span fait de la
politique il a également affirmé qu'il
n'écarterait qu'aucun vaccin en fonction
de son origine
disons qu'un bon vaccin est un bon
vaccin concernant le sésame de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
les tirs du vaccin ce piquet a débuté le
5 mars et devrait durer peut-être même
jusqu'à fin mai s'il obtient le feu vert
il devra bien sûr être utilisé dans
toute l'union européenne
épidémie de covin 19 dévastatrices en
bosnie également avec un taux de
mortalité en rapport à sa population
très élevé face à la propagation du
virus les autorités peinent à trouver
une stratégie vaccinale et cherche des
alliés vers qui se tourner et détaillée
avec meslier ski fis et quentin voeckler
des hôpitaux saturés les pompes funèbres
débordés les cimetières forcé de
s'adapter dans la banlieue de sarajevo
des dizaines de thon sont creusées tous
les jours à cause de l'épidémie de kovy
de 19
la situation est très difficile et grave
notre personnel travaille 24 heures sur
les chiffres sont implacables
parallèlement le nombre de patients
augmente tout comme le nombre de décès
le taux de mortalité a été élevé ces
derniers mois par rapport aux derniers
mois le taux de mortalité est plus élevé
de 300 % avec 2 119 décès pour cent
mille habitants
la bosnie herzégovine 1 des taux de
mortalité lié aux kovy 19 des plus
élevés au monde
selon l' agence de santé publique de
sarajevo le coc vite 19 a fait plus de
18 5 morts par jour en mars dans la
capitale
dans le même temps la bosnie ne vaccine
que très peu sa population avec un pays
divisé en trois entités
les gosses tiens ne possède pas de
ministère de la santé à l'échelle
nationale la politique sanitaire peine à
convaincre la population
lundi dernier plus d'un millier de
bosnie sont descendus dans les rues de
sarajevo pour demander la démission du
gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un combat
pour la vie nous avons dit précisément
ce que nous voulions nous voulons une
démission du gouvernement bosnien parce
qu'il n'a pas fait le travail pour
lequel il est très bien payé
nous voulons des solutions acceptables
nous voulons des démissions nous voulons
des vaccins nous voulons qu'un haut
niveau gouvernement élabore dans les
quinze jours un plan
et un programme pour résoudre la crise
épidémiologique dans les entités et dans
tout notre pays
vous pouvez me croire le droit à la
vaccination est un droit universel et en
regardant ce drapeau de bosnie
herzégovine ici j'ai versé une larme
parce que ce devrait être un pays fier
et non un pays qui reçoit des dons de
vaccins alors que six états membres de
l'ue pouce pour accélérer le processus
d'adhésion de la bosnie à l'union
européenne
sarajevo reste en marge des décisions de
bruxelles
la bosnie herzégovine n'est pas
prioritaire dans la coordination
vaccinale des états en europe
en parallèle sarajevo est réticent à
l'idée de se rapprocher de la russie
pour obtenir le vaccin foot nick v
par peur de compromettre son dossier de
candidature a lieu en attendant le pays
s'est tourné vers le programme kovacs
lancé par l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
une première livraison de 23 mille
quatre cents doses du vaccin father
biotech est arrivé le 25 mars
et on apprend ce soir que l'europe a
recensé plus d'un million de morts du
comique 19 depuis sa découverte en chine
en décembre 2019
ailleurs dans le monde l'inde devient le
deuxième pays le plus touché de la
planète à la pandémie
derrière les etats unis malgré plus de
13 millions de calais fête religieuse
hindoue ce sont tout de même déroulée
sans aucune distanciation et une
centaine de milliers de nouveaux cas ont
été enregistrés pour la seule journée
d'hier florian lambert des images de
liesse populaire qui contraste avec un
bilan sanitaire alarmant des dizaines de
milliers de croyants hindouistes se sont
rassemblés près du grand fleuve mythique
pour des prières traditionnelles qui
semble ignorer toutes distances assure
sociale
nous n'avons pas peur dieu est avec nous
c'est de ça dont les gens devraient
avoir peur
cela nous fait du bien nous n'avons pas
peur il n'y a pas de commande un virus
l'inde en situation sanitaire critique
sur la seule journée de ce lundi
168 1912 nouveaux cas de contamination
que 8,19 ont été enregistrés l'inde qui
devient ainsi le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde derrière les états unis
avec plus de 13 millions de malades du
coronavirus pourtant les autorités la
sueur avec 100 millions de doses
administrées en 85 jours
l'inde affirme mener la campagne de
vaccination la plus rapide au monde
devant la chine et les états unis en
janvier les autorités indiennes avaient
formulé l'objectif de 300 millions de
personnes vaccinées d'ici le mois de
juillet une population d'1 milliard 300
millions habitants
les autorités indiennes ont approuvé ce
mardi le recours au vaccin en russe foot
nick v pour une utilisation d'urgence et
pour en parler nous sommes avec 4 l'aude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison on l'a vu que la situation
était très critique dans son vin d'un
l'inde qui recherchent aussi des vaccins
qui utilisent même le vaccin russe
pourtant le pays a une très grosse
capacité de production
oui les indiens ont développé les plus
grosses capacités de production de
vaccins dans le nom d'ailleurs
traditionnellement l'inde approvisionne
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
des organisations de l'onu qui vaccinent
massivement en afrique / pour toutes
sortes de maladies et c'est la même
chose donc pour les vaccins contre le le
govic 19 alors d'ailleurs l'inde a
approuvé depuis quelques temps déjà
depuis le début de l'année un vaccin
indien qui a été fabriqué en ahl qui a
été inventé en inde
et puis par ailleurs elle a un accord
avec les fabricants de l'astra et des
cas pour fabriquer ce vaccin dans une
usine à des quantités tout à fait
importante et au à partir d'aujourd'hui
il ya donc le beau location du vaccin
russe spoutnik v et j'ai noté que
le dirigeant de de la société qui a
financé ce vaccin rude ce site et russe
qui a financé ce vaccin a déjà passé au
cours des mois précédents cinq accords
de fabrication avec des grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques indiens qui
sont d'ailleurs des entreprises privées
et que 100 millions par ci de 100
millions par là en tout c'est près de
900 millions de doses qui vont être
fabriqués par ses laboratoires indiens
alors évidemment il va falloir le temps
et fabriquer certaines doses seront
prêtes dans les prochaines semaines
d'autres seront prêtes au mois de
juillet mais c'est en effet un résultat
important et narendra modi comme vous
l'avez dit a promis de vacciner 400
millions d'indiens d'ici le mois de
juillet il a déjà atteint le niveau de
100 millions mais comme vous l'avez dit
aussi la population indienne et est
extrêmement nombreuses et il ouvre cette
vaccination à tous les vins dhien qui
ont un âge au dessus de 45 ans à partir
de maintenant
donc il a besoin évidemment de tous les
vaccins possible et cela est un élément
de la lutte contre la pandémie mais ça
n'est pas le seul justement quel est
l'autre stratégie mais à part les
vaccins du pays alors narendra modi a
exposé sa stratégie à la télévision pour
expliquer à tous les indiens que en
effet ensemble ils avaient vaincu la
première vague en réalité karima maudit
avait décidé il ya un an d'un
confinement très dur de tout le pays
en utilisant de ces pouvoirs
exceptionnels dus à la pandémie et
pendant près de deux mois
l'économie indienne s'est arrêté les
travailleurs précaires parce qu'il ya
beaucoup il ya un secteur informel qui
est très important en un sont retournés
dans le désordre dans leurs campagnes et
l'économie a été
il appela pendant cette période alors il
a expliqué hier à la télévision
il ne s'agissait pas de refaire la même
chose bien entendu puisque cette fois ci
on a les vaccins et que par conséquent
il recommandait un confinement
spécifique 1 micron confinement par dans
les zones qui sont particulièrement
touchés il a également recommandé un
couvre-feu pour la nuit et un certain
nombre d'autres mesures qui sont grosso
modo celle qui sont appliquées dans
différents pays d'europe
mais la grande différence avec la france
en tout cas c'est que l'inde est un pays
fédéral et que la compétence sanitaire
revient aux 22 états et que le centre
des lilas de pouvoir direct que sur neuf
sujets qui sont dire qu'ils dépendent
directement de la capitale donc il faut
convaincre les chief minister des
différents des 22 états et c'est cela
que ce à quoi s'emploie monsieur maudit
un petit peu comme madame merkel le fait
avec les ministres en chef avec les
ministres présidents des différents
länder et ça n'est pas simple mais la
pandémie gagne puisque bombay a décidé
c'est le gouvernement du maharashtra
qu'il a décidé d'un confinement alors
qu'il s'agit de la capitale économique
et financière du pays et que d'autres
villes sont en train de faire la même
chose des lits et 20 alors la capitale
delà de la technologie de l'informatique
ont décidé d'un couvre-feu et d'un black
out pendant les week-ends ou moins
pendant un mois donc on a une situation
d'urgence qui va marcher sur deux pieds
d'un confinement sélectif et puis les
vaccinations et vaccination à outrance
puisque le pays en a le moins les moyens
quelles conséquences économiques et
politiques de cette stratégie du premier
ministre alors la conséquence économique
que ça d'abord été que le confinement
des
on a provoqué une baisse de la
production une baisse du pib de l'inde
de 20% ce qui est considérable mais
l'économie étant suffisamment flexibles
l'inde a retrouvé le niveau d'avant
ce confinement est donc d'avant la
pandémie dès le mois dernier et par
conséquent avec un taux de croissance
quoique le fonds monétaire international
prévoyez pour l'année 2000 21 un taux de
croissance de 12 et demi pour cent pour
l'économie indienne
mais ça c'était avant la deuxième vague
et avant les mesures qui sont en train
d'être prises dans les grandes villes et
dans les grands centres où il y à un
regain de contagion alors la première
conséquence ça va être celle ci est
effectivement le jeu pour les
responsables est de doser le confinement
sans arrêter l'économie est un peu le
problème qu'on a connu et qu'on pouvait
l'on connaît encore dans nos pays dans
nos pays européens
et puis l'autre conséquence politique
c'est que l'inde avait promis de
distribuer des vaccins gratuitement aux
pays voisins notamment aux deux pays
l'himalaya le népal et le bhoutan mais
aussi ses pays voisins de l'est ce que
sont le bangladesh et la birmanie
et puis aux îles que sont les villes
d'agde livres ou même un peu plus loin
l'île maurice 20 millions de zone
gratuitement et que là devant la
pandémie l'inde a été obligé de
d'interdire les exportations de vaccins
la priorité c'est de vacciner les
indiens et par conséquent bien jeu
malheureusement les doses qui était
promise à l' oms ou à d'autres
organisations de l'onu bien les
organismes devront attendre pour les
pour les recevoir
sur le plan politique c'est plus
difficile parce que l'inde connaît
actuellement des élections dans
plusieurs grands états notamment au west
bengal calcutta et calcutta a toujours
voté depuis 30 ans pour des chief
minister d'opposition au gouvernement de
delhi quels qu'ils soient est
actuellement
madame mamata banerjee cherche à obtenir
un troisième mandat et se bat dans une
élection qui dure
plusieurs semaines parce que il faut
faire voter 90 millions de personnes et
se bat contre un candidat bjp et
soutenue par le premier ministre une
arène mahmoudi et je pense que dans ces
conditions et on retrouve la même chose
au kerala roux la même chose au tamil
nadu
les partis politiques ne voudront sans
doute pas faire ce que la reine ramolli
leur demande c'est à dire une sorte
d'union nationale pour traiter la
pandémie là la politique a aussi ses
droits et évidemment la d'études très
grande démocratie et il faut que les
élections se tiennent dans ces trois ou
quatre états comme cela a été planifié
merci je maison expert en relations
internationales merci d'avoir été avec
nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
nouvelle polémique autour de l'école
privée musulmane albertville en savoie
[Musique]
c'est couper des ménages que mich dej
udom et bordeaux a10 et a13 une commande
à tout autre résultat que vous tenez pas
en service et téléphonie tours 4
beyrouth a sorti ce jeudi à nicosie
commande chez des brigades canines
moteur à dakar aux macarons aux machines
des beastie boys est parfois du mal à
surnager la politique française la torre
du jeu sony mytischi dj est idéal chez
d'autres outch manager d'aston garde à
vue d'esprit
e
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dit aux nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
21h30 heure française souhaité bienvenue
en direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez le sénat bien de donner son
feu vert pour un amendement concernant
la loi sur le séparatisme qui donnerait
au préfet le pouvoir de s'opposer à
l'ouverture d'un établissement scolaire
privé cela alors qu'une école musulmane
albertville fait polémique
un peu plus tôt dans la journée le
président a l'air de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes avait enjoint les autorités
à empêcher l'installation de cette école
privée dans une lettre envoyée au
président de la république le maire
d'albertville avaient tenté de bloquer
le projet en contestant devant la
justice le permis de construire déposé
par l'association islamique mais il a
été débouté par le tribunal
administratif qui lui elle l'a validé
alors l'implantation d'une telle école
et l contraire aux valeurs de la
république peut-on imposer sa
construction au maire c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec abdallah zekri président de
l'observatoire de l'islamophobie au
conseil français du culte musulman
bonsoir abdallah zekri merci d'être avec
nous a ajouté gilbert à bergl abergel
pardon président du comité laïcité
république bonsoir gilbert albert gène
merci d'être avec nous avant de
commencer ce débat en cette information
de dernière minute donc le sénat qui a
donné le feu vert à un amendement de
toute dernière minute au projet de loi
précisément sur le séparatisme pour
permettre au préfet de s'opposer à
l'ouverture d'une école hors contrat je
cite soutenu par un état étranger au
style évidemment suite à cette polémique
aujourd'hui sur l'école d'albertville
votre réaction abdallah zekri
écoutez je crois c'est sérieux du tout
le sénat mais ça existe déjà
le préfet est là déjà la possibilité
d'interdire l'ouverture d'une école hors
contrat
donc c'est uniquement de la
communication comcom à chaque période
électorale naturellement vous savez pour
ouvrir une école hors contrat il voit
autorisation du procureur de la
république celle du préfet celle du
rectorat et celle du maire donc par
conséquent déjà il faut ces
autorisations là et si parmi eux
refusent l'ouverture de nettoyage se
fera pas au tram est maintenant je vous
dis c'est de la communication de pickles
cette histoire de chat ce cas ci n'est
pas signé il ya naturellement à donnera
pas de la part de certains hommes
politiques et l'amalgamé qui est en
train d'être fait les écoles hors
contrats existent elles sont heureux d'y
livrer pendant cinq ans après 52 des
écoles avec contrat maintenant je suis
entièrement d'accord
il ya une école qui parle le séparatisme
qui ne veut pas respecter les valeurs de
la république et c'est qu'on l'a fait
même si elle est ouverte à la ferme
et si elle
l'interdît mais qu'on arrête un petit
peu de faire l'amalgamme ça je ne suis
pas d'accord parce qu'actuellement
malheureusement on est dans une période
où tout ce qu'ils cachent sur l'islam et
les musulmans
gilbert abergel quand elle a écrit nous
disent de toute façon c'est de la
communication quentin si un maire ne
veut pas faire ouvrir une école privée
n'ouvrira pas c'est pas exactement ça
manifestement vu la polémique de la
journée parce que le tribunal
administratif lui a dit bah si le maire
veut pas mais on a le droit de
construire du moment qu'elle permis de
construire c'est bien ça oui de toute
façon que je réfute totalement le
discours de monsieur 7,7 cette idée
d'islamophobie et de ressortir cette
allure d'arguments de l'islamophobie
pour contrer toutes les toutes les
initiatives de la république pour
justement limiter à l'emprise de
l'islamisme radical
ses yeux c'est absolument insupportable
et ça dure et ça dure alors ce n'est pas
que de la communication
en fait c'est un peu comme si le
gouvernement avait anticipé ou avoir
répondu très vite à nos préoccupations
puisque en l'état actuel de la
législation il était impossible de
d'interdire la la construction de cette
école et vous l'avez dit très
administratif s'est prononcé simplement
sur 17 des conditions de d'urbanistes
icain dix ans de parkings et autres
aujourd'hui il faut effectivement
accepté cette idée que nous ne sommes
pas suffisamment équipés pour résister à
ce genre d'intrusion et de tentative de
séparatisme il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont
le projet de loi actuellement en
discussion apporte un certain nombre de
réponses 1 dans le contrôle justement de
ces lieux de prière il manquait ce petit
élément qui donnait le pouvoir donc au
représentant de l'état d'interdire et de
s'opposer à la construction de tels de
tels établissements
pour des raisons qui tiennent alors que
je lis le texte de l'amendement pour des
raisons qui tiennent aux relations
internationales de la france où la
défense de sa souveraineté
lorsqu'il s'agit bien de cela mulet go
russe n'en est pas à sa première
création vie le bonus grâce à un nombre
de mosquées
bruce gère d'autres écoles et ce qui est
enseigné dans cette école
ce ne sont pas les respect des valeurs
de la république on va avant de faire
réagir dallas zekri bien sûr on va
écouter laurent wauquiez il est un peu
ce sur votre lit bien le président a
l'air de la région auvergne rhône-alpes
qui a dû être entendue manifestement par
emmanuel macron hills qui lui est
adressé une lettre
écoutez laurent wauquiez l'école serait
un établissement hors contrat dont
l'orientation consistera très clairement
à promouvoir des valeurs qui ne sont pas
celles aujourd'hui de la république
voilà les éclisses s'agit de valeurs qui
ne serait pas en phase avec la
république comme le dit laurent wauquiez
est ce que c'est aussi soustraire à
jeunesse turque eux à la république je
vais vous donner un chiffre que vous
connaissez certainement mais qui dit
beaucoup 400 élèves 1 sur une ville qui
en compte 1200 ça fait quasiment un
quart des élèves scolarisés qui seraient
susceptibles d'aller dans cette école
vous comprenez que ça puisse faire peur
si ce n'est pas conforme à la république
justement je viens d'écouter monsieur
sur le plateau il a raison le milieu
gauche il a d'autres écoles hors contrat
et si c'est quand les ont été vérifiés
j'ai été contrôlé il le sait très bien
que ces gosses ont contrôlé une fois par
an avec des contrôles inopinés
on n'attend pas les gens et jusqu'à
maintenant on n'a rien trouvé à redire
maintenant toujours l'intégrisme je suis
citoyen français quand tout le monde de
concussion gillman je tombe à
l'intégrisme
je compte par doris jeu quand pas ce qui
semble
notre pays j'ai toujours dénoncé on les
a toujours des lancers mais là moi je
marche sur le plan légal
ce monsieur mais l'ego ruche à un
terrain il faire construire un lieu de
culte
le maire sur le pense il va au tribunal
qu'il entende raison
bon maintenant et il appartient au
préfet au procureur au maire etc
de son côté moi je parle uniquement sur
le plan légal après on nous dit dépens
de la turquie lui facture que moi je
suis le français de confession musulmane
je suis d'origine algérienne
j'aime la france moby je n'ai jamais dit
que j'avais pas mal d'hommes habillés
d'origine alors dit qu'on aime son pays
d origine
anéanti français je suis désolé j'ai
même pays il ya deux écoles hors
contrats juillet des écoles hors contrat
catholique
lorsqu'un problème était qu'il s'agit
d'une école hors contrat pour des
musulmans a commencé à trouver des
histoires de parc et ceci dit cela moi
je lui suggère où il ya des preuves
concernant la radicalisation de lugos
ruche et bien des preuves comme pas et
zubi saïbi étranger à ce moment là on
est dissout travailler gilbert a bien
fallu que dans les pentes mais mais
monsieur d'abord je n'ai jamais contesté
votre attachement à la république je
n'ai jamais je me suis jamais jamais
prononcé contre l'islam en tant que tel
enfin il faut être aveugle pour ne pas
que me legal c'est quand même une
piscine qui est au match aller l'outil
d' influence du pouvoir turc actuel il
faut pas oublier que le président r
doigts lorsqu'il est venu je crois en
2018 a fait une déclaration disant mais
je vous considère comme qu'on ne touche
pas aux musulmans je vous considère
comme les enfants que les ans les
tentatives d'intimidation sont multiples
on ne parle pas d'une école sous contrat
enfin hors contrat qui ferait qui mettra
en place des méthodes pédagogiques
particuliers route
on parle d'une école gérée par une
association qui on le sait on le sait
les enquêtes le long des monts selon
démontrer fait une oeuvre deux
d'intrusion dans les valeurs de la
république
c'est on est là dans dans la la
diffusion de valeurs opposées à celles
de la république
imaginez
vous madame vous le disiez quatre cents
400 enfants mais comment est ce que nous
voulons que l'on sait depuis sept ans en
voilà voilà sur l'île déserte
comment voulez-vous que l'école de la
république trouve sa place
comment voulez vous que l'on fasse
société avec une telle initiative
comment voulez-vous que l'école de la
république
elle puisse trouver sa propre place et
alors vous parliez effectivement de vous
aviez à vous parler de deux lois
effectivement notre loi aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisamment structurée n'est
pas suffisamment complète pour éviter ce
genre de manifestation on peut se
référer effectivement à la liberté qui
aiguise aux mains d'un autre pays de
créer des associations
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est libre de
créer qu'on est libre aussi de perturber
les principes
avant de vous faire un lien vers nous
avec vous je suis d'accord avec vous on
n'est pas là pour perturber le principe
il expliqué devant une chose le migou
ruche et appellent encore trois quatre
mois ils étaient reçus au ministère de
l'intérieur
mais découvrir des façons ils ont été
reçus par deux à maquereau a divisé
alors qu'on m'explique comment ça se
fait qu'une association qui prend
l'avion soit reçue sous la nature
allemand les faces de la république
cher monsieur vous savez comme explique
ce tombe explique cela alors vous savez
qui a été le créateur de bus légaux
russe
je n'ai pas vous l'apprendra monsieur
necmettin à nice la liste antisémite qui
a été premier ministre en turquie entre
96 et 97 et était ensuite mis dehors par
l'armée turque que le tout et qui a
porté les valeurs de milli gorus très
tôt clic ya un style et ses propres
valeurs
mais alors on sait parfaitement que la
stratégie de milieux russes ce n'est pas
d'apparaître comme une association
conquérante
c'est bien de se mouler à dents dans les
institutions d'en percevoir les points
faibles à ce qu'on appelle la taqiyya et
puis justement de croatie gré de la
recette de ces règles de liberté de
cette démocratie on revient toujours à
ce que
pour perdre peut partir cette école pour
pervertir ces lois écrit avant de faire
réagir aux propos justement de gilbert
abergel je voudrais vous faire écouter
le maire d'albertville à un principal
concerné dans cette affaire puisqu'il
s'est opposé à cette construction
écouter l'intention affichée du cmj est
de créer une école privée prodiguant un
enseignement hors contrats sur des bases
et des valeurs premières qui ne sont pas
celles de notre république
il milite en faveur d'une partition
territoriale qui polarise la vision de
la société entre nous et eux il est
urgent que le parlement adopte des
dispositions législatives adapté pour
permettre aux maires de contrer
l'installation d' associations ou des
entreprises piloté par des puissances
étrangères qui favorise une
cristallisation identitaire au coeur de
nos territoires
ça dans les écrits c'est quelque chose
que vous réfutez totalement parce que
j'imagine que vive notre fonction au
conseil français du culte musulman vous
vous connaissez donc ce sujet par coeur
pour vous minigo russe n'est pas dans
cette description que nous en fait le
maire d'albertville
non je suis je suis désolé le maire s'il
a des preuves qu'il est battable si je
ne fais pas de par les trois cantons
je suis désolé il dit qu'il restait pas
les valeurs de la république qu'il
apporte les preuves qu'ils respectent
pas la république
moi je connais ce monsieur je ne suis
pas de gauche je ne suis pas du tout
dans l'eau un socialiste et miss
d'ailleurs je vous signale cancer' de
galles fait une visite en france
c'est officiel
sexy ambassade de turquie bah oui ceux
qui ne sont pas rendus là ces qui s'est
pas rendue pour toucher la barre à une
chaîne locale est allé prendre le verre
de thé avec huit autres sont allés le
rencontrer alors donc je suis et je peux
et je suis vite on parle beaucoup et
dans ce que dans le but d'analyser le mr
bah il défend il ne veut pas cette école
je comprends ça va rendre les 400 écoles
de 400 enfance de 1200 je comprends très
bien sa réaction
mais vous savez le centre dans un pays
de droit tout ce qu'il dit si devant un
tribunal il ne peut pas apporter les
preuves de ce qu'il dit et de ce qu'ils
avancent maintenant qu'il y ait des lois
nouvelles pour interdire ces contrats la
loi c'est la loi
on respectera la loi et je demanderai à
eau à ces gens-là de respecter la loi
mais aujourd'hui je suis désolé la
justice est de leur côté
ce n'est pas moi réseau de côté la
justice et leur côté à l'automne maison
gibert un verger cet intéressant ce que
ton dit abdallah zekri parce que le fait
et c'est que la justice est
effectivement de leur côté comme vient
de le dire le tribunal administratif
dans la mesure où aujourd'hui on peut
ouvrir une école si on en a le droit
donc emmanuel macron selon vous vous
l'avait dit en début de ce débat bien
fait de demander cet amendement au
ministre de l'intérieur en sachant je le
répète que ces écoles hors contrat
soutenu par un état étranger au style
comment définit-on un état étranger
hostile après la diplomatie mais je te
rappelle ce que je disais au début de
notre entretien et que nous avons écrit
notre communiqué aujourd'hui en état
actuel de la réglementation
effectivement on n'a plus de moyens
d'interdire l'implantation de cette
école et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons appelé à une des quelques
précision dans le dans le cas du projet
de loi qui est actuellement en débat au
sénat pour que justement le représentant
de l'état plus disposer des moyens
nécessaires à l'interdiction de ce2 ce2
de ces de ses créations là alors après
on rendre de la diplomatie comment faire
pour qu pour désigner secte ivement
l'état ça reviendrait à daisy d'état
turc comme un état intrusif au sein de
la république ça appartient aux
diplomates
mais en tout cas on aura quelques outils
on pourra le faire
abdallah zekri le mot de la fin ce qui
frappe ici c'est que le gouvernement
ensemble emmanuel macron le premier
semble découvrir ce soir à la faveur de
cette polémique médiatique il y à ce
problème que finalement on peut créer
des écoles hors contrat séparé de la
république ou pas d'ailleurs que ça
comme vous le dites semble légal
aujourd'hui en france il sauve les gars
que 10 de ce génial je connais pas qui
est en train de défendre le dossier
d'une manière orale est juste qu'il faut
il a parlé de relations internationales
dans la salle des pneumatiques
imaginez que demain la turquie le maroc
l'algérie la tunisie telecom française
et ça n'a pas su prétexte à ce que et
dépendre de l'étranger ou qui s'en sont
les sandales et à l'étranger apprend
qu'entre dit on fait quoi
la turquie mais il faut parler il faut
parler d'arabie saoudite
tout ce qu'ils achètent à part milliards
de décimales parisien des équipes de
foot de l'argent détourné pour acheter
des immeubles
enfin il faut laisser la somme la vendée
pro matic mans il faut traiter le sujet
d'une manière globale
peut-être le mot de la fin monsieur
abergel jeu peut que se dire que c'est
écrit dans cette déclaration et man
chassons l'argent sale partout il est
aussi étant dit monsieur mac on n'a pas
découvert le la situation au cours des
derniers événements puisque dès son
entrée en fonction il avait déclaré
qu'il refuserait de voir la turquie
faire en france ce qu'elle a fait en
allemagne
voilà donc ça fait un moment que les
services français interpelle le
gouvernement font des notes étudie
analyse nous avons des études
qualitatives et quantitatives pour
démontrer justement que ces stratégies
sont nuisibles à la halle équilibre de
notre épine nuisible au bon
fonctionnement de l'école de la
république
il était temps que notre république se
dote de l'arsenal juridique lui
permettant d'y mettre un peu d'ordre
manifestement aujourd'hui à la faveur de
cette polémique je le rappelle un
puisque cet amendement est un amendement
de toute dernière minute merci en tout
cas tous les deux abdallah zekri et
gilbert abergel d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce face à face merci à vous deux
dans le raid
dans le reste de l'actualité guillermo
olaso nouveau président de l'équateur et
promet un pays libre et démocratique un
scrutin sur fond d'aggravation par la
pandémie de la crise économique que
traverse le pays
les gloires douce et le président
sortant équatorien lenin moreno connaît
son successeur et c'est un homme de
droite qui dirigera le pays pour les
quatre prochaines années
le conservateur guillermo olaso ex
banquier s'est proclamé président de
l'équateur avant même la fin du
dépouillement le 24 mai prochain nous
assumerons avec responsabilité et le
défi de changer le destin de notre
patrie et à atteindre pour tous
l'équateur d'opportunités de prospérité
auquel nous aspirons
face à lui le jeune économiste andré
sahara où ce protégé de l'ancien
président socialiste rafael correa a
abdiqué
reconnaissant sa défaite dans les urnes
c'est un revers électoral mais ça ne
signifie pas une défaite politique ou
morale monsieur l'assaut je vous appelle
à respecter l'état de droit
je vous demande de respecter l'état de
droit la haine ne sert à rien discutons
démocratiquement sans que ce soit une
menace pour les citoyens
guillermo olaso pourra notamment pour
défi de redresser l'économie de
l'équateur très touchée par les
conséquences de la pandémie de kovy 19
l'état sud-américain qui déplore plus de
17000 décès liés au virus aux états unis
donald trump refait parler de lui et
continue de régler ses comptes l'ancien
président américain s'en est pris aux
chefs des républicains au sénat qu'il a
tenus responsables de l'attaquant
janvier d'un
du capitole invité d'honneur d'une
réunion des donateurs le milliardaire
indiqué qu'il n'avait aucun doute de la
reprise du sénat et de la chambre des
représentants en 2022
donald trump qui s'est aussi attribué le
mérite d'avoir développé un vaccin
contre le coc ville il devrait s'appeler
trump seen at il précisé et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec
jean-claude beaujour vice président du
cercle de réflexion france-amérique
avocat en droit international
bonsoir jean todt bonjour merci soit
avec nous alors un discours prononcé
devant les instances du parti
républicain plutôt insultant quand même
en tout cas très offensif peut-il
laisser des traces à ce qu'il marque le
grand retour de donald trump nouvelles
troupes n'est jamais parti vous vous
souvenez que à la fois il a eu du mal à
quitter la maison blanche il a eu du mal
à reconnaître sa défaite
il est il s'est un peu terré dans sa
superbe résidence de floride
mais en réalité il n'a jamais caché ses
intentions son intention c'est de
continuer le combat il a dit très
récemment il va continuer le combat
alors sur sa route
évidemment il ya des démocrates aux
forces il ya la nouvelle administration
mais il ya surtout le sort du parti
républicain il souhaite évidemment faire
main basse sur le parti républicain
parce que même si une base électorale
absolument importante que j'évalue à au
moins un tiers de l'électorat qui a voté
pour lui au moins un tiers des 74
millions de voix qui se sont portées sur
son nom
et bien qu'il sait qu'il aura besoin à
la fois des lui qu'il aura besoin d'un
parti et il veut absolument chasser
j'ai envie de dire il n'est qu'un site
les notables du parti républicain dont
il s'en prend tout d'abord à à l'ancien
chef ancien leader des républicains au
sénat je rappelle que
c'est aussi l'époux de l'ancien ministre
de donald trump qui elle-même avec
démissionner un peu après l'atteinte du
capital donc on voit bien que donald
trump essaie de se débarrasser d'un
certain nombre de deux dirigeants du
parti républicain en particulier les
plus anciens et lancy login temps
d'assurer les futurs candidats en leur
disant si vous voulez être élu ou réélu
lors du prochain scrutin de mi-mandat
alors rejoignez nous rejoignez moi donc
c'est un véritable bras de force qui
s'ouvre est donc pour moi ça laissera
c'est pas simplement laisser des traces
mais il part en guerre contre les
responsables du parti et c'est
probablement une démarche politique et
d'atik bien pensé avec l'objectif
jean-claude beaujour 2024 eh bien je
pense que le premier objectif c'est de
gagner les élections mi-mandat
deuxième objectif de se positionner
comme le véritable opposant de joe de
joe baden de manière à apparaître comme
le candidat naturel de la droite
républicaine lors du prochain scrutin
naturellement tout ça est encore bien
loin il y a encore beaucoup de dents but
sur le chemin du futur candidat quel
qu'il soit d'ailleurs mais en tout état
cause les choses sont rythmées pour être
pour s'organiser si besoin est comme
cela
alors la crise sanitaire également dans
un tram s'attribuent le mérite du vaccin
il insulte au passage le docteur fois
aussi le conseiller médical en chef de
la présidence
rien de nouveau a finalement baissé
dirigée contre joe biden qui n'aurait
pris col roulé oui alors là on n'est pas
surpris
alors évidemment il a le la
caractéristique de l'ancien président
des états unis c'est de forcer le trait
vous imaginer que les hommes politiques
font très souvent cela en réalité ils se
rendent bien compte qu'il a pris le
train un peu en retard sur cette
histoire de coronavirus qu'en réalité je
baden amine ensemble à aa fait de la
crise sanitaire un axe de campagne faure
et qu'aujourd'hui
ben 185 millions moment je m'exprime 187
millions d'américains ont été vaccinées
3 millions d'américains sont vaccinés
tous les jours et en principe si tout se
passe bien
cinquante pour cent de la population le
sera le 9 mai et fin juin 75 % de la
population
donc il y aura une immunité collective
aux états unis aux alentours du début
juillet ce qui veut dire que le pays va
pouvoir repartir économie de points donc
il est évident que donald trump ne veut
pas perdre un petit bout de ce qu'ils
pourraient s que humainement peut
considérer comme une victoire pour les
républicains parce que les démocrates
pardon pour l'administration baden c'est
pas simplement une victoire politique
mais c'est une victoire économique
sociale parce que le peuple américain
souffre beaucoup de de cette crise
sanitaire et donc joe biden entend
entendra sans aucun doute un tir est
largement profit de ceux de sa démarche
et donald trump n'a pas envie d'être en
reste par rapport à ce sujet
certainement pas envie d'être en reste
qu il pense même à créer son accent
donald trump top trumps in apparemment
comment est accueillie cette idée aux
états unis ccc crédible alors je vous
répondrai à la fois il ya deux angles de
réponses possibles ya l'angle
scientifique
et puis il ya un angle politique l'angle
seuls les scientifiques peuvent vous
dire où en sont et éventuellement ses
équipes sur de la recherche on ne crée
pas un vaccin comme cela je ne sais pas
qui l'ancien président des états unis a
derrière lui pour pouvoir faire de la
recherche
un vaccin et puis subir les tests qui
existe aux états unis 2 à des formules
différentes devises sur le marché c'est
en tout état de cause sur le plan sur le
plan politique il est il est certain
qu'ils viennent petite minorité de
supporters de donald tranquille de
toutes les façons vous diront que vous
diront que donald trump est capable de
tout et qui le croiront à côté de cela
vous avez le reste de l'amérique qui
pour laquelle c'est beaucoup moins la
préoccupation la paire préoccupation je
vais vous dire sur le terrain la
préoccupation des américains ce n'est
plus tellement de batailles donald trump
joe madden parce que cela s'est terminé
aujourd'hui nos nounous concitoyens
américains ont une préoccupation les
américains ont une préoccupation c'est
la possibilité de pouvoir recommencer à
travailler c'est la possibilité de
pouvoir payer leurs dettes n'oubliez pas
qu'il ya des risques
c'est la possibilité de pouvoir se
soigner pour ceux qui sont ceux qui sont
malades est atteint du virus
et pour cela vous savez très bien qu'il
y à un système social protecteur qu'en
europe donc je pense que c'est là
aujourd'hui
là où se trouve la plage la
préoccupation de l'américain moyen
le reste est relativement marginale
merci jean todt vaujour d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre analyse et
c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain point
complet sur l'actualité dans quelques
petites minutes avec emilie gobin
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry allons
faire connaissance vous avez choisi le
jour à bagdad alors je suis arrivé en
2005 pour étudier dernière fois celle en
profiter en 2011 le monde manque pas un
petit peu non ah oui c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
l'été arrive ou de ce qu'ils pouvaient
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative en
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé nombre de banques à
suivre monsieur rendent c'est quelque
chose qui nous a emmenés dans une
catastrophe en 2007 et en 2008
tous les tous les crédits ficelé goldman
sachs et morgan stanley était évidemment
pas au courant les uns des autres
quartiers gosses avaient autant
d'engagements à droite à gauche et c'est
en principe de l'opacité de la chose
peut l'annoncer dès maintenant vous
aurez des archers gosses en x 10
[Musique]
un pas de plus vers la vaccination
désormais ouverte à tous les français
avaient de 55 ans et plus ce sera avec
astrazeneca mais aussi johnson & johnson
dès mercredi
le délai entre les deux injections d
maxence weiser et moderna et lui allongé
but est de vacciner et plus alors que
certains vaccinodromes ont été stoppés
dans leur élan haute dose en pleine
reprise des discussions sur l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire l'iran accuse
israël d'avoir saboté un de ses
complexes nucléaires dans le même temps
téhéran a également fermement condamné
les nouvelles sanctions annoncées par
l'union européenne outre lui
responsables iraniens vous paierez le
chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne reçus
demain à l'otan les mouvements de
troupes russes à la frontière vont être
évoquée moscou est préoccupé par la
situation l'armée ukrainienne aurait
commencé à bombarder la banlieue de
d'onet réaction des ministres des
affaires étrangères du g7 il appelle la
russie à cesser ses provocations et à
engager une désescalade frontières de
l'ukraine qui maintenir son rang
nucléaire et spatial c'est ce que
souhaite bladimir poutine en cette date
anniversaire il ya 60 ans youri gagarine
devenait le premier homme à voyager dans
l'espace
la russie lui a rendu hommage
aujourd'hui
la conquête spatiale
[Musique]
je
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france la vaccination
connaît un coup d'accélérateur en france
car ses amis mecque le gouvernement
s'est fixé le déconfinement comme
objectif et pourtant le manque de doses
se fait ressentir le pays va toutefois
pouvoir compter sur la livraison d'un
nouveau vaccin l'américain johnson &
johnson plus de précision avec notre
reporter thomas bonnin on est passé du
nombre record de 510 milles injection
vendredi dernier à 100 milles ce
dimanche alors c'est quand même plus que
le dimanche précédent mais une
illustration de ce ralentissement c'est
le fait que le stade de france
transformée en vaccinodromes été fermé
ce dimanche faute de dos faute de
personnel on ne peut pas être dans le
rythme sept jours sur sept
souhaitée par le président de la
république en tout cas dans ces
vaccineront mots il faut rappeler aussi
que le principe même de vacciner drôme
avait d'abord été écartée par le
ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qui a donc finalement
changer de braquet mais pour s'assurer
de l'efficacité de ces immenses centres
de vaccination il va falloir compter sur
un approvisionnement important en
matière de doser pour accélérer le
rythme le gouvernement va bientôt
pouvoir compter sur un nouveau vaccin
celui de johnson & johnson disponible à
partir de mercredi en france deux cent
mille doses devrait arriver dans le
courant de la semaine selon les
autorités sanitaires
avantage important pour le calendrier
fixé par le gouvernement
ce vaccin ne nécessite qu'une seule
injection cela va permettre de vacciner
davantage de personnes surtout que
depuis ce lundi la vaccination est
ouverte pour toutes les personnes âgées
de 55 ans et plus
mais face aux craintes de pénurie
olivier ferrand également annoncé l
espacement du temps entre les deux
injections pour les vaccins arn
messagers ce temps va passer de 28 à 42
jours à partir de mercredi
présentée comme une évolution des
connaissances scientifiques cet
aménagement va surtout permettre de
vacciner davantage enfin autre nouveauté
cette semaine dans la lutte contre le
comique 19 la mise sur le marché en fin
des autotests après des longs mois
d'hésitation la france faisait exception
puisque
ces autos tests sont déjà largement
répandu dans un certain nombre de pays
européens ils sont donc enfin disponible
depuis ce lundi aux personnes de plus de
15 ans sur le territoire français
initialement il avait été prévu qu'il
puisse être vendu ses hôtes au test en
grandes surfaces ils ne sont finalement
disponibles qu'en pharmacie seulement
des syndicats de pharmaciens alerte sur
le peu d'informations qu'ils possèdent
concernant l'encadrement de ces auto
test et puis aussi sur la faible
quantité de stocks qu'ils ont reçu ces
derniers jours il faut dire qu'une
grande partie de ces autos tests ont été
acquis par l'état qui souhaite les
mettre dans les établissements scolaires
en vue de la rentrée prochaine et zoom
justement sur johnson & johnson
désormais disponible en france c'est le
quatrième vaccins utilisés dans
l'hexagone deux cent mille doses
devraient être livrés à compter de ce
lundi par john seine la filiale
européenne du groupe pharmaceutique
américain
alors quelles sont les particularités de
ce nouveau venu
éléments de réponse en images deux cent
mille doses du vaccin johnson and
johnson seront livrés les premières
arriveront en france avec une semaine
d'avancé dès ce lundi 12 avril contre le
19 avril initialement
d'après les annonces du ministre de la
santé dans les colonnes du journal du
dimanche selon les résultats des essais
cliniques ce vaccin ne serait efficace
qu'à 85 % contre les formes graves du
coït 19 le sérum et efficace à 66% pour
prévenir les formes modérées à sévères
de la maladie
c'est moins que les vaccins de pfizer
bio high tech et modern art
cependant c'est de ces roms ont été
testés cliniquement alors que les
différents variant du virus n'était pas
encore connue le vaccin johnson &
johnson ne nécessite qu'une seule
injection
un avantage logistique il peut être
conservé trois mois dans des
réfrigérateurs à température standard ce
qui facilite sa distribution
l'agencé européenne des médicaments a
lancé une étude sur des liens possibles
entre ce vaccin est l'apparition de
caillots sanguins
après que quatre dont un mortel ont été
recensées pour le moment aucun lien de
causalité n'a été établie selon
l'autorité américaine de régulation
le laboratoire johnson and johnson
étudie l'effet de deux doses au lieu
d'une seule
jusqu'à présent des chercheurs ont émis
des